GOOD
AFTERNOON EVERYONE AND WELCOME
TO THE ASSEMBLY LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE IS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON
SAFEGUARDING OUR FRONTLINE
WORKERS DURING COVER NINETEEN
THE NEED FOR ROBUST WORKPLACE
HEALTH AND SAFETY PROTECTIONS
ON A SOUTHERN ROSS KALRA HONOR
TO CHAIR THIS COMMITTEE- AND
THIS HEARING IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT ONE I'M SO GLAD THAT
WE'RE GETTING PARTICIPATION
FROM A NUMBER OF COLLEAGUES
THAT INCLUDES COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SOME RELEASED RIVAS WAS HERE
WITH US- IN THE SUMMER GONZALEZ
AND JONES SAWYER. AS WELL AS
VICE CHAIR OF FLORA AND- A
SUMMER CAREER OVERALL GOING TO
BE PARTICIPATING OR WATCHING IN
REMOTELY- IN IN VARIOUS FORMS
BUT- THEY'RE ALL VERY
INTERESTED. IN THIS ISSUE- I
THEN- IN A- WE HAVE WITH THE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BEAVIS AND IS A
MEMBER OF RESURFACES HERE
SUMMER PROBABLY THIS. WILL BE
WITH US IN A MOMENT- THANK YOU
ALL FOR BEING UP BY
PARTICIPATING- EITHER HERE OR
REMOTELY- IN THIS IMPORTANT
HEARING AND DUE TO THE
CONTINUED. STAY AT HOME
MORTARBOARD FOR WHERE WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
YEAR THE HEARING ROOM. AT THREE
O'CLOCK THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING I'M ONLY HAVE ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
ACTUALLY PARTICIPATE IN PERSON.
OUR ALSO REQUIRE THAT MASS BE
WORN AND PHYSICAL DISMISSING
THE MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS.
OF THE PUBLIC PROVIDING COMMENT
WHETHER HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT
A VIDEO CONFERENCING SITE. IF
YOU DO NOT HAVE A MASK BE CAN
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU SUPP. A
TODAY'S HEARING FOCUSES ON- I
ALSO WANT TO MENTION THAT WE DO
HAVE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER ELECT
ALEX LEE WHO'S HERE WITH US AS
WELL- AND WE APPRECIATE HIS
INTEREST IN THIS ISSUE AND
BEING HERE. IN ADVANCE OF HIS
ANSWERING AND WE APPRECIATE IT.
THANK. YOU GRADUALLY HIM ON HIS
VICTORY.I TODAY'S HEARING ON
PROBLEM WORK HEALTH AND SAY IN
LIGHT OF CODE NINETEEN WE TALK
ABOUT FRONT LINE WORKERS WERE
AFRAID OF THE WHO J. INTO WITH
THE PUBLIC AND ARE OFTEN
ESSENTIAL TO THE WELL BEING OF
OUR ECONOMY. THESE WORKERS HAVE
NO CHOICE BUT TO GO TO WORK
EVERY DAY RISKING THEIR LIVES
AND THEIR HEALTH AND- THEIR
FAMILIES. ENSURING THAT WORKERS
CAN SAFELY DO THEIR JOBS HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A PRIORITY OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND ITS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. IN TIMES OF A PANDEMIC
WE ARE EVEN MORE CONCERNED THAT
HEALTH AND SAFETY POLICY
ARTICLE YOU PROTECT OUR
WORKERS. EDUCATE OUR EMPLOYERS
ABOUT THE RESPONSIBILITIES AND
ENABLES WORKERS TO DISCLOSE
SAFETY CONCERNS WITHOUT FEAR OF
RETALIATION. I SEE OUR
DISCUSSION TODAY AS PART OF A
BROADER PART PROCESS TO
IDENTIFY THE GAPS IN THE
STATE'S RESPONSE TO WORKER
SAFETY DURING VOTED. AND OFFER
RECOMMENDATIONS TO CREATE A
MORE ROBUST FRAMEWORK FOR
PROTECTING WORKERS ACROSS ALL
INDUSTRIES. WE'LL HEAR FROM TWO
PANELS MADE UP OF KEY
STAKEHOLDERS GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS AND ADVOCATES. FOR
EACH PANEL WILL HAVE SOME TIME
FOR THE MEMBERS ASK QUESTIONS
AT THE END OF THE HEARING WE
WILL TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT. THE
AND AS ALWAYS WHEN. I HAVE
THESE INFORMATIONAL HEARINGS AS
CERTAINLY AS CHAIR. OF THIS
COMMITTEE THE IDEA REALLY IS TO
SPARK. THOUGHT CONVERSATION BUT
ALSO JUST TO LISTEN AND WILL BE
LISTENING NOT ONLY. THIS IS
OVER SHE GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
BUT ALSO FROM WORKERS. AND
EVERY TIME WE'VE HAD A HEARING
OF THIS NATURE AND HAS
SUBSEQUENTLY LED TO EITHER
LEGISLATION OR BUDGET US
THEY'RE RELEVANT TO THE TOPICS
AT HAND SO. I REALLY ENCOURAGE
NOT JUST THE MEMBERS THE
MEMBERS STAFFS- TO REALLY PAY
ATTENTION AND TO USE THIS. AS A
WAY OF SPARKING IDEAS YOU MAY
HAVE AS TO WHAT WE CAN DO MORE.
TO PROTECT WORKERS. UP FOR OUR
FIRST PANEL- THE MODIFIERS ARE
FIRST AND I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
FOR SMALL COMMITTEE MEMBER.
SOME OF THESE RIVAS AND SHE
LIKED. MAKE ANY COMMENTS. OKAY
THANK YOU SO RIVAS I BELIEVE WE
ALL HAVE A SOME UP COMMITTEE.
THAT MADE ON THE LINE ZERO
CINEMA. OR OTHERS- BUT IF THERE
IS ANYONE THAT'S- ALREADY
HOOKED UP AND READY TO GO IF
THEY LIKE TO MAKE ANY COMMENT.
THIS IS THROUGH THE WEB ACTS SO
I'M HOPING. THAT THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO AND- THEY CAN ALWAYS
CHIME IN. WHATEVER THEY LIKE
BUT WANTED TO AN OPPORTUNITY
RIGHT NOW. OKAY WELL. IF THEY
IF THEY DO WANT TO WHAT YOU'RE
HOPING TO BE ABLE TO- AND SO-
AND THEN FINALLY OF COURSE IS A
MEMBER OF ALWAYS WEARS WERE
VERY VERY HAPPY TO HAVE YOU
HERE WITH US AFTER THIS HEARING
THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE TIME
TO BE HERE ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. THANK YOU SO MUCH I WANT
TO BEGIN BY THANKING. THE
TICKET. THANK THE MICROPHONE ON
THE SHOULD BE ON. I DO WANT TO
BEGIN BY THANKING YOU MISTER
KALRA CHAIR OF LABOUR COMMITTEE
PROVIDED ME TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS HEARING TODAY I WANT TO
THANK YOUR STAFF ALSO FOR ALL
THE WORK THEY DID TO PREPARE-
SO THAT WE CAN DO IT ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE. WHEN WE ALL LEFT
THE CAPITAL EARLIER THIS YEAR
WE WERE UNCLEAR REGARDING THE
DEATHS OF THIS PANDEMIC THAT'S
AFFECTS ON OUR COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY. OUR WORKING
FAMILIES WHO DON'T HAVE THE
CHOICE TO WORK FROM HOME. ONCE
UPON BY AND WE STILL ARE
UNCLEAR ABOUT THE LONG LASTING
EFFECTS OF THIS PANDEMIC BUT WE
MUST BEGIN TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES THAT HAVE RESULTED
ALREADY THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
IDENTIFIED. AND TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE. IT'S OUR DUTY TO SERVE
AND PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES AND
THIS HEARING ALLOWS US AS
LEGISLATORS TO SEE WHERE THE
GAPS ARE IN THE PROGRESS. AND
ENSURE WE'RE ALL DOING OUR BEST
TO PUT THIS PANDEMIC BEHIND US
AND TO HELP OUR WORKERS. I AM
CURIOUS TO HEAR FROM OUR FIRST
PANEL SPECIFICALLY FROM CAL
OSHA. OTHER CRITICAL STEPS
THEY'VE TAKEN TO PROTECT THE
SAFETY OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
WORKERS. AND HOW THEY PLAN. TO
IMPLEMENT PROVISIONS FROM. MY
BILL AB SIX EIGHTY FIVE WHICH
ENHANCED HELLO THIS IS A
MINORITY TO INVESTIGATE. FIND
REGULATE REQUIRE COMPLIANCE
AND- EVEN SHUT DOWN BUSINESSES
THAT REFUSED TO COMPLY. AND WHO
ARE PUTTING THEIR WORK LIVES OF
THEIR WORKERS IN DANGER. I ALSO
WANT TO ESPECIALLY WELCOME
EVERYONE FROM OUR SECOND PANEL
AS WELL. AS YOUR VOICES AND
THOSE OF YOUR MEMBERS ALLOW US
TO KNOW FIRST HAND WHAT OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE EXPERIENCING.
FOR WHAT FOR THE LEADERSHIP OF
U. F. C. W. AND CALIFORNIA
LABOR FAT AND OTHER LABOR
UNIONS WE WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO PASS A B. SIX EIGHTY
FIVE. I AND OTHER. SIMILAR
LEGISLATION THAT PROTECTS OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
BUT AS WE ALL KNOW NO
LEGISLATION PASSES WITH ONLY
ONE SIDE BEING HEARD SO I
SINCERELY APPRECIATE THE
WILLINGNESS OF OUR BUSINESS
COMMUNITY TO COME TO THE TABLE
AND PUT THE SAFETY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR WORKERS
FIRST. WANT TO THANK THEM ALL
FOR THEIR COMMITMENT TO
PROTECTING THE WORKERS OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SUMMER RAINS- SO FOR
OUR FIRST PANEL. THE FIRST
PANEL PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF
WORKER HEALTH AND SAFETY POLICY
DURING COLLEGE. I WILL CHOSE
ALAMO PRINCIPLE FISCAL AND
POLICY ANALYST WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
AND MOST WILL START WHICH IS
ALSO GOING TO HAVE DUBBED
PARKER. WHO'S THE CHIEF OF CAL
OSHA AS WELL AS YOUNG SON
PARKER THE CHEAP CHIEF DEPUTY
SECRETARY SPEAKING FOR SPANISH
IS AT THE LABOR AGENCY- ANIMAL
AND WAS STEVEN KNIGHT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF WORK SAFE AS WELL
AS KAREN I'M FOR THE STOP
ATTORNEY FORCING SO WE'RE GONNA
START- SIX MINUTES- WITH- CHAS
ALAMO SO- THE JAZZ RADIO. THANK
YOU MA'AM. JEFF MEMBERS CAN YOU
ME YEAH WE CAN HEAR YOU YOU.
GOOD AGAIN MY NAME'S CHAS ALAMO
I COVER LABOR EMPLOYMENT ISSUES
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE AND OUR OFFICE WAS ASKED
TO PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
KALPOE SHOT. AND THE STEPS
COUCHES TAKEN SINCE A PANDEMIC
BEGAN FIRST FOR TODAY'S
HEARING- WITH OUR TESTIMONY WE
PREPARED A BRIEF HAND OUT I
HOPE YOU HAVE THAT IN FRONT OF
YOU. THEY HAD THAT IS AVAILABLE
ON THAT THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE
FOR THOSE THAT ARE INTERESTED.
I'M SO ON ON THE- PAGE ONE OF
THE HAND OUT I'M STARTING HERE
THE CALIFORNIA. DIVISION OF
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH-
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR PROTECTING
WORKERS BY ENFORCING WORKPLACE
SAFETY AND HEALTH STANDARDS-
AND THEY DO SO- IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE FEDERAL OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY. AND HEALTH
ADMINISTRATION. OP THE DIVISION
NOTICED HOW OSHA IS DIVISION
WITHIN THE STATE'S DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS AND
BOTH OF THEM ARE HEADQUARTERED
IN OAKLAND- THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. BUDGET PROVIDED A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT CAL OSHA-
THE MAJORITY OF THIS FUNDING
COMES FROM AN ASSESSMENT ON
EMPLOYERS WORKERS COMPENSATION
INSURANCE PREMIUMS- ON THAT THE
SECOND LARGEST COMPONENT IS UP
FEDERAL GRANT. FOR THIRTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
FEDERAL OSHA AND THE REMAINDER-
IS VERY UPSET SPECIAL FUNDS.
THAT THE BUDGET AUTHORIZED
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
POSITIONS FOR CALLOW SHOT
STATEWIDE- OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS DIVISION HAS
OPERATED WITH A RELATIVELY HIGH
VACANCY RATE- THAT PICKING THE
RIGHT RIGHT NOW HOVERS AROUND
20% FOR ITS STAFF- WHICH IS
ALMOST TWICE AS HIGH AS THE
STATEWIDE AVERAGE VACANCY. AND
THE BAY AREA REGION DISTRICT
OFFICES. AND ARE THE COUCHES
ACTIVITIES CAN CAN SORT OF FALL
UNDER FOUR BROAD CATEGORIES AS
WE SEE IT- THE FIRST IS THAT
CALLOSUM. CONDUCTS
INVESTIGATIONS IN RESPONSE TO
COMPLAINTS AND REPORTS OF
INJURY OR ILLNESS- THE SECOND
THAT IT IT CONDUCTS TARGETED
INSPECTIONS ARE IN HIGH HAZARD
INDUSTRIES. IT ALSO CERTIFIED
HIGH RISK PROJECTS ARE
ACTIVITIES AND FINALLY I MAKE
CONDUCTS EMPLOYER OUTREACH
THROUGH ITS CONSULTATION
SERVICES BRANCH. ON ON PAGE TWO
OF THE HAND OUT BECAUSE A
SECURING IS FOCUSED ON FRONT
LINE WORKERS OFFICE PREPARED A
BIT OF BACKGROUND ON THE
STATE'S FRONTLINE WORK FORCE-
FRONTLINE WORKERS REGULARLY
INTERACT WITH BOTH CUSTOMERS
AND COLLEAGUES- WITHIN CLOSE
PHYSICAL PROXIMITY AND AS- AS
THE CHAIR MENTIONED AS A RESULT
MAY FACE HEIGHTENED EXPOSURE TO
THE CORONA VIRUS- DURING THE
REGULAR WORK ACTIVITIES.
THERE'S NO SET DEFINITION OF
WHAT INDUSTRIES ARE OR ARE NOT
FRONT LINE- TO WE ADOPTED ON A
DESIGNATION FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH-
NEED SUMMER GUIDANCE ON TESTING
PRIORITIES TO PREPARE THE TABLE
AND I IN THIS SHEET. AND AS YOU
CAN SEE TYPICALLY GOING INTO
THE PANDEMIC THAT THERE WERE
ABOUT FIVE POINT SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIA WORKERS WORKING IN
FRONT LINE INDUSTRIES- THE
LARGEST INDUSTRIES WERE
HEALTHCARE- FOOD SERVICES AS
WELL AS- GROCERY CONVENIENCE
AND DRUG STORES. AND YOU CAN
SEE ON THE RIGHT HAND COLUMN OF
THIS TABLE THAT AVERAGE ANNUAL
PAY BY THESE INDUSTRIES VARIES
CONSIDERABLY SO ON THE HIGHER
END- YOU HAVE THE HEALTHCARE
INDUSTRY PUBLIC SAFETY AND
CORRECTIONS AS WELL AS PUBLIC
TRANSIT. AND ON THE LOWER END
OF THE PAY SCALE YOU HAVE THE
JANITORIAL WORK FORCE- CHILD
CARE WORKERS AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS AND GARMENT WORKERS. WE
THINK OUR ROUGH ESTIMATE IS IT
TYPICALLY ABOUT ONE THIRD OF
THE STATE'S WORK FIRST WORK IN
THE FRONT LINE INDUSTRY. I'M
THE TURNING TO PAGE THREE AND
SPECIFIC TO CAL OSHA'S RESPONSE
TO CHRONIC VIRUS PANDEMIC-
CALLUSES TAKEN TWO PRIMARY
STEPS SINCE A PANDEMIC BEGAN
AND THE FIRST STEP WAS WORKING
IN COLLABORATION WITH OTHER
STATE ENTITIES ISSUING VARIOUS
INDUSTRY SPECIFIC COVERT
NINETEEN WORKPLACE. SAFETY AND
HEALTH GUIDANCE SO GUIDANCE
MEASURES SPECIFIC TO DIFFERENT
TYPES OF INDUSTRIES. THE SECOND
PRIMARY STEP AND ONE THAT I
WANT TO FOCUS ON TODAY- HAS TO
DO WITH HOW CALLOSUM RESPONDS
TO COMPLAINTS THAT IT RECEIVES
FROM AN EMPLOYEE'S. ON IN LIGHT
OF ANTICIPATED WORKLOAD
INCREASES DUE TO CULVERT
NINETEEN- CAL OSHA HAS
TEMPORARILY ADJUSTED ITS
PROTOCOL FOR HOW IT RESPONDS TO
COMPLAINTS. AND BY THAT I MEAN
THAT GOING FORWARD WITH THIS
HEIGHTENED WORKLOAD CAL OSHA
WILL CONDUCT FEWER ON SITE
INSPECTIONS IN RESPONSE TO
COMPLAINTS AND INSTEAD ISSUE.
MORE LETTERS TO EMPLOYERS HI IN
RESPONSE TO COMPLAINTS THE
LETTERS. IDENTIFY THE ALLEGED
VIOLATION. AND REQUIRE THE
EMPLOYER TO INVESTIGATE THE
ALLEGATION AND SERENITY- ANY
ANY SHORTCOMING- IF ONE IS
FOUND. TYPICALLY CAL OSHA
RECEIVES ABOUT TWELVE THOUSAND
OF THESE EMPLOYEE COMPLAINTS A
YEAR. AND TYPICALLY RESPONDS TO
ABOUT 20% OF THOSE COMPLAINTS
BY CONDUCTING AN ONSITE
INSPECTION. SENSE THE CORONA
VIRUS PANDEMIC BEGAN CAL OSHA'S
HAS ALREADY RECEIVED MORE THAN
ITS TYPICAL ANNUAL NUMBER OF
COMPLAINTS A WORKLOAD AS WELL
OP. BUT AT THE SAME TIME DUE TO
THE ADJUSTED PROTOCOL I
MENTIONED JUST A MOMENT AGO
HELLO SAYS. TRIGGERING A
COMPLAINTS ARE TRIGGERED
TRIGGERING AN ONSITE INSPECTION
IN ABOUT 6% OF CASES OF THIS IS
BELOW THE TYPICAL TO A NORMAL
CONDITION INSPECTION RATE OF
TWENTY PERCENT. ON THOSE
NUMBERS MIGHT JUMP OFF THE PAGE
BUT I DO WANT TO CAUTION NOT TO
PRE JUDGE CAL OSHA BASED ON
THIS DISTINCTION THAT THERE
COULD BE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
BENEATH THESE NUMBERS THAT.
THAT OP MISTER PARKER CAN SPEAK
TO- AFTER MY TESTIMONY BUT IT
IS ONE DISTINCTION THAT WE
WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT- THAT THAT
CARILLO SHUT HAS EXPERIENCED
OVER THE LAST EIGHT MONTHS OR
SO. ON THE FOURTH PAGE OF OUR
HAND OUT- BRIEFLY SUMMARIZES
THE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE
INFORMATION ON THAT CITATIONS
AND VIOLATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
ISSUED BY CAL OSHA SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO COVERT NINETEEN. I'M
IN TOTAL THE DIVISION IS JUST
ABOUT A MILLION DOLLARS AND
CITATIONS AND THEY'RE LARGELY-
IN JUDE AND MEAT PROCESSING
INDUSTRY- AMONG THE GROCERY
STORES. AND AT HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES AS YOU CAN SEE IN
THE IN THE FIGURE HERE ON ON
PAGE FOUR- I WOULD POINT OUT
THAT. ALL OF THE INDUSTRIES
THAT HAVE RECEIVED CITATIONS-
WHERE VIOLATIONS WERE FOUND ARE
CONSIDERED FRONT LINE
INDUSTRIES- AS THE CHAIR
BROUGHT UP EARLIER. AND THE
FINAL PAGE OF OUR HAND OUT IS
SORT OF PARTING QUESTIONS THAT
WE THINK THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MIGHT WANT TO KEEP IN MIND AS
THEY HEAR FROM OTHER EXPERTS
AND THE PANELISTS- AND THESE
QUESTIONS BONTA TWO CATEGORIES
WE THINK. THE FIRST GROUP OF
QUESTIONS. HAS TO DO WITH CAL
OSHA'S CURRENT STAFFING LEVELS
AND ITS VACANCY RATE AND WHAT
THE STAFFING LEVELS ARE
SUFFICIENT TO ENFORCE WHEN DOES
THE STATE'S LABOR STANDARDS.
UNDER NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES AND
WHETHER THERE ARE SUFFICIENT
UNDER THESE EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES. AND THAT THE
SECOND GROUP OF QUESTIONS HERE
IN THE HAND OUT HAS TO DO WITH
CALLUSES COMPLAINT RESPONSE
PROTOCOL. AND IN ESSENCE TRYING
TO GET OUT WHAT THE PRACTICAL
EFFECT. OF THE ADJUSTED
COMPLAINT RESPONSE PROTOCOL HAS
BEEN AT CAL OSHA THAT IS-
CONDUCTING FEWER ONSITE
INSPECTIONS AND RELYING MORE
HEAVILY ON EMPLOYEE LETTERS-
TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF WHAT
THE PRACTICAL EFFECT THAT THAT
ATTACK ON OUR WORKPLACE SAFETY
AND HEALTH- IN THE LAST EIGHT
MONTHS. WITH THE TIME THANK YOU
AND- HAPPY AS I WILL BE ON THE
LINE FOR QUESTIONS AT THE IN
THE PANEL THANK YOU SO MUCH YES
I DID MENTION EARLIER WILL
HAVE. ABOUT FIFTEEN MINUTES FOR
QUESTIONS OF THE ENTIRE PANEL
AFTER ALL THE PANELISTS FOR A
CHANCE TO SPEAK FOR THIS. FIRST
ROUND SO THANK YOU A MEASURE
ALL AMOUNT. OF MONEY AND- LET'S
MOVE ON. TO DOUG PARKER OF THE
CHIEF OF CAL OSHA TESTIFYING
REMOTELY FROM OAKLAND AND YOUNG
SON PARK. CHIEF DEPUTY
SECRETARY CITIES COMPARTMENT
AND INITIATIVES THAT THE LABOR
AGENCY BY PHONE. AND YOU BOTH
HAVE A TOTAL OF EIGHT MINUTES
AND SO. FEEL FREE. TO DON'T
DIVIDE YOUR TIME ACCORDINGLYTHANK YOU. A GOOD AFTERNOON-
CHAIR KALRA VICE CHAIR FLOORS
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE- I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ABOUT
CALLUSES RESPONSE THE COVERT
NINETEEN. CRISIS I WANT TO
FIRST THANK FIRST RESPONDERS
AND ESSENTIAL WORKERS- AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR CONTRIBUTIONS
AND SACRIFICES. DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME- THEY HAVE
CONTINUED TO. FEED US TRANSPORT
US CONSTRUCTOR HOMES- NOW
PROVIDE US WITH HEALTH CARE.
AND THE ESSENTIAL NEEDS OF A
SOCIETY AND- TOO MANY OF THEM
HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES PROVIDING
THOSE SERVICES. WE HAVE BEEN
FOCUSED A CALLOUS ON PROTECTING
THOSE ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO.
WHO FACE THE GREATEST RISKS AND
WE HAVE ATTEMPTED TO MAINTAIN
THE HIGHEST STANDARDS OF WORKER
PROTECTION DURING THIS CRISIS-
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A NATIONAL
LEADER IN WORKER HEALTH AND
SAFETY STANDARDS. AND
MAINTAINING THOSE HIGH
STANDARDS OF EMPLOYER
RESPONSIBILITY HAS BEEN OUR
GOAL AS WE APPROACH THESE
CHALLENGES- I THOUGHT TO BE
HELPFUL TO PROVIDE THE
COMMITTEE WITH AN OUTLINE OF A
HOW WE'VE RESPONDED TO THE
CRISIS. WE DID REALIZE EARLY ON
THAT WE HAD TO HAVE A STRATEGY
THAT WAS GOING TO PROTECT
WORKERS AND DO IT ON A SCALE
WELL BEYOND OUR CAPACITY TO
ADDRESS WITH THE NORMAL TOOLS
OF DOING- AND- INSPECTIONS OR
OTHER INTERVENTIONS ON A
WORKSITE BY WORKSAFE BASIS- SO
FIRST. WE KNEW WE WOULD HAVE TO
LEVERAGE KNOWLEDGE AND
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE- TO DEVELOP
GUIDANCE AND NOW AN EMERGENCY
OF A STANDARD. REGULATIONS THAT
WOULD COVER WORKERS SO THAT-
WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS WOULD
UNDERSTAND HOW THEY COULD
MINIMIZE RISK OF TRANSMISSION
TO COVER NINETEEN- SECOND WE
HAD TO FIGURE OUT. HOW TO
DISSEMINATE THAT KNOWLEDGE BY
FINDING WAYS TO EDUCATE AND
CONDUCT OUTREACH WITH AS MANY
EMPLOYERS AND WORKERS AS
POSSIBLE. AND THIRD WE HAD TO
FOCUS OUR ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS
AND LEVERAGE THEM IN A WAY THAT
WOULD PROVIDE THE GREATEST
IMPACT FOR WORKERS WITH HE
FINITE RESOURCES THAT- WE HAD
TO COMMIT TO- THIS EFFORT- IN
ADDITION OF THOSE THREE AREAS
WE'VE ALSO HAD TO DEVOTE
CONSERVATORY SOURCES TO
CAPACITY BUILDING. A CALIPHATE
BY ADDRESSING THE RELATIVELY
HIGH VACANCY RATE- AND THE NEED
FOR MORE PARTICULARLY
INDUSTRIAL HIGH JANICE TRAINED
TO RESPOND TO HAZARDS SUCH AS
COVER NINETEEN. WITH RESPECT TO
THE FIRST STRATEGY- IN MARCH AS
THE- AS THE CONSULTANT WAS
SAYING WE'D EXPECT AGAIN
DEVELOPING- ACROSS AGENCY LINES
AND- THROUGHOUT THE DAY WORKING
WITH- CDPH COBRAS AND OTHER.
OTHER AGENCIES IN THE STATE
GUIDANCE FOR A WIDE RANGE OF
INDUSTRIES- AND YOU KNOW WE'VE
ISSUED- THE GUIDANCE FOR ALMOST
FORTY DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES-
THOSE ARE AVAILABLE ON OUR
WEBSITE WE DON'T CONSIDER BY
OUTRAGE TO EMPLOYERS ON THOSE
ISSUES. WE'VE ALSO RECENTLY
COMPLETED DEVELOPMENT OF AN
EMERGENCY TEMPORARY STANDARD OF
REGULATION THAT WOULD PROTECT
CALIFORNIA WORKERS FROM COVER
NINETEEN- THOSE WHO ARE NOT
COVERED BY OUR AEROSOL
TRANSMISSIBLE DISEASES
STANDARD- THAT IS A- PROPOSAL
THAT WILL BE VOTED ON BY THE
STANDARDS BOARD ON NOVEMBER
NINETEENTH. AND IF APPROVED
WILL PROVIDE VERY STRONG BUT
ALSO ACHIEVABLE PROTECTIONS FOR
WORKERS- ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
WILL BE THE NEW CLEAR
STANDARDS. ON EMPLOYER PROVIDED
HOUSING AND TRANSPORTATION THAT
WE'VE PROPOSED IN THAT
EMERGENCY STANDARD- THESE ARE-
ISSUES MOST COMMON IN
AGRICULTURE- TO HELP REDUCE
COVER NINETEEN TRANSMISSION IN
THESE PARTICULAR HIGH RISK
SITUATIONS- WE'VE ALSO DONE
EXTENSIVE EDUCATION OUTREACH
OUR SECOND STRATEGY- AND I'LL
LEAVE- SOME OF THE ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION TO MY- COLLEAGUE-
YOUNG SON PARK TO DISCUSS MORE
OF THAT- BUT ONE OF THE THINGS
I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT-
THAT ENSURES. THAT OSHA HAS
DONE RECENTLY IS TO DEVELOP AN
ONLINE TRAINING ACADEMY- SO
THAT WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS CAN
ACCESS ONLINE TRAINING ON THE
CALLOSUM WEBSITE- EMPLOYERS CAN
USE IT TO SUPPLEMENT THEIR
TRAINING THEY CAN TAKE TRAINING
ON HOW TO DEVELOP A PLAN IN
THEIR WORKPLACE AND THEN
WORKERS CAN DIRECTLY ACCESS
TRAINING- SO THAT THEY KNOW
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES. ON A THIRD
STRATEGY- IT OUR STRATEGY HAS
FOCUSED ON TARGETING THE
HIGHEST RISK WORKPLACES AND
INDUSTRIES. FOCUSING ON
GEOGRAPHIC HOT SPOTS- AND THEN
COMMUNICATED OUR FORSMAN
EFFORTS TO THE PUBLIC TO
FURTHER INCENTIVIZE COMPLIANCE.
WITH OTHER CLOSE TO FIFTEEN
HUNDRED COVER NINETEEN
INSPECTION SINCE FEBRUARY-
WE'VE ISSUED CITATIONS. THAT
WILL HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
DETERRENT THE FACT INCLUDING
CITATIONS AT A MEAT PACKING
PLANT. THAT ARE THE HIGHEST
MONETARY PENALTIES IN THE
COUNTRY. AND WE HAVE ACTIVELY
PUBLICIZE OUR FORSMAN EFFORTS
TO INCENTIVIZE THAT COMPLIANCE.
OUR STRATEGIC FOCUS HAS BEEN IN
HEALTHCARE AGRICULTURE RETAIL
AND MANUFACTURING. HOME WE'VE
ALSO MADE SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS
ON HIRING- AND HAVE- OF THE
GIRL OF ABOUT SIXTY FIVE- HIRES
THAT WE- I HAVE SET FOR- MAKING
BY THE END OF THE YEAR WE HAVE
THIRTY SEVEN HIRES- THAT WE
HAVE EITHER- ON WHICH WE'VE
EITHER MADE OFFERS ARE THERE IN
THE FINAL STAGES OF. OF THE
REVIEWER THE INTERVIEW PROCESS
SO WE ARE- OPTIMISTIC THAT
WE'LL REACH OUR COMPOSED AT
LEAST TO THAT GOAL. WELL WE'RE
ALWAYS LOOKING FOR WAYS TO DO
OUR JOB BETTER WE BELIEVE OUR
APPROACH IS THE RIGHT ONE AND-
WE'VE MADE SIGNIFICANT IMPACT-
I CAN- ADDRESS SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE RAISED BY
THE CONSULTANT. YEAH IN OUR
QUESTION PERIOD- I'LL- RESERVE
THERE ARE OTHER LEAVE THE REST
OF THE TIME THAT WE HAVE FOR
THIS PARK. THANK YOU. I AM
OPTING FOR QUESTIONS AT THE END
OF THE PANEL THE YOUNG SON PARK.
MAY I THINK YEAH I THINK SHE'S
TALKING ABOUT- MY PHONE. HEAR
ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU HELLO
YES OKAY THANK YOU A GOOD
AFTERNOON YES I WILL ELABORATE
ON THE LABOR AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCIES OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR
DEPARTMENTS TO REALLY- INCREASE
AND ENHANCE THE PUBLIC
AWARENESS AND EDUCATION OF
WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS- ON THIS
ISSUE AT THE STATE APPROPRIATED
THIRTY TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS Q. THE LABOR AGENCY AND
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS IN SEPTEMBER FOR THE
EXPLICIT PURPOSE OF PROTECTING
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND ULTIMATELY SLOWING
THE SPREAD. OF THE VIRUS YOU
EDUCATION COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
AND ENFORCEMENT- SO WE ARE
LAUNCHING A VERY COMPREHENSIVE
CAMPAIGN THAT TAKES THREE
STRATEGIC APPROACHES THE FIRST
IS PUBLIC AWARENESS THROUGH
MEDIA THAT WOULD BE BOTH
TRADITIONAL AND DIGITAL MEDIA
STRATEGIES THE SECOND IS
COMMUNITY OUTREACH THROUGH
TRUSTED MESSENGERS INCLUDING
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
OTHER NONPROFITS ARE THEY CAN
REACH- WORKERS AND EMPLOYERS-
IN THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND
THEN THE THIRD ARE MORE-
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EMPLOYERS AND WORKERS Q. ENGAGE
AND EITHER VIRTUAL WORKSHOPS OR
OTHER INTERACTIVE SESSION TO
REALLY LEARN HOW TO ADOPT. SOME
OF THE GUIDELINES AND
REQUIREMENTS AROUND A LABOR
PROTECTIONS. TO PREVENT CO THAT.
NINETEEN THE WORK- THE TO.
THAT- WILL BE A IN THESE ASTER
OUT AFTER IN WERE IT'S HELPING.
ARE THEY ALL DOING PAGE LEAVE-
AND OTHER- LEAVES BENEFIT
ACCESS TO WORKERS COMP. AND
ANTI RETALIATION PROTECTIONS-
AND WE WILL ALSO BE
PRIORITIZING REGIONS THAT ARE
HARDEST HIT AS WELL AS THE
HIGHER RISK INDUSTRIES MANY OF
WHICH HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED.
EARLIER IN THIS HEARING- I KNOW
THAT I AM OVER TIME AND SO WANT
TO BE AVAILABLE FOR ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE SEPARATE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ELABORATING ON THE
COALITION'S EFFORTS AND- I'M
SURE IT'LL BE A QUESTIONS AND-
COMMENTS AFTER THE PANEL'S OF
THANK YOU BOTH THE MISTER
PARKER IN HIS POEMS PARK- NOW
CAN MOVE ON. TO COMPLETE THE
PANEL THE FINAL TO. SEE KNIGHT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF WORKSAFE
FALL BY KAREN I'M FREE A STAFF
ATTORNEY FOR WORKSAFE AND THEY
ALSO HAVE. EIGHT MINUTES SURE
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE MISTER
KNIGHT ALREADY READY TO GO ON
THE VIDEO. YES THANK YOU CHAIR
KALRA NUMBERS- STEVEN KNIGHT
WITH WORKSAFE WHERE AN
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO
PROMOTING THE RIGHTS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO A SAFE AND
HEALTHY WORKPLACE. ALL MAKES
AND- GENERAL OVERALL. COMMENTS
IN MY COLLEAGUE CARRYING. WORK
IS MARKED BY MASSIVE DISASTERS
THAT SPUR ACTION THE TRIANGLE
SHIRTWAIST FIRE NINETEEN ELEVEN
IS A NOTABLE EXAMPLE THE CORONA
VIRUS PANDEMIC IS THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY DISASTER OF OUR
LIFETIME. WE NOW KNOW THEIR
WORK PLACES ARE MAJOR SITES OF
COVERT TRANSMISSION WORK PLACES
ARE RECEIVING AND GENERATING
COVERT CASES SPREADING
INFECTIONS AND SENDING WORKERS
HOME TO THEIR FAMILIES. JUMMA
REPORTS AS MANY AS HALF OF ALL
ADULTS ARE ENDANGERED BY
WORKPLACE EXPOSURE. QALISYA WAS
HARDLY THE ONLY GOVERNMENT
AGENCY UNDER PREPARED FOR THIS
CORONAVIRUS. A SINGLE WIDELY
REPORTED CITATION EARLY IN THE
PANDEMIC. I COULD HAVE GOTTEN
THE ATTENTION OF EMPLOYERS AND
ACROSS THE STATE AND IMPROVE
PUBLIC HEALTH AMID A PANDEMIC
THAT IS HAVING AN OUTSIZED
IMPACT ON COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
YEAH WE SAW NO ENFORCEMENT
PUBLIC ENFORCEMENT UNTIL
SEPTEMBER. THE BOTTOM LINE IN
PROTECTING WORKPLACES WORKERS
VOICES ARE VITAL. SOME
EMPLOYERS SUBJECT TO THE
NECESSARY FOCUS SOME WORK
PLACES BUT WE ARE ALL DEEPLY
IMPACTED DISADVANTAGED AND
PAYING A COST AS WE STRUGGLE TO
SAVE THE LIVES OF CALIFORNIANS.
WORKSAFE STANDS WITH A POWERFUL
MOVEMENT OF WORKERS AND UNIONS
WHO HAVE ADVOCATED SINCE SPRING
FOR AN EMERGENCY TEMPORARY
STANDARD. FOR TEMPORARY
DISEASES OR ETS WHICH THE STATE
ALREADY HAS FOR MEDICAL
WORKPLACES AS CHIEF PARKER JUST
MENTIONED CAL ISSUE DELIVERED A
DRAFT LAST WEEK IT'LL BE VOTED
ON THIS THURSDAY. THE PROPOSAL
IS BASED ON SOUND SCIENCE AND
PUBLIC HEALTH PRINCIPLES IT
BUILDS ON EXISTING REQUIREMENTS
SUCH AS THE INJURY AND ILLNESS
PREVENTION PROGRAM. IT IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE GUIDANCE
ISSUED BY CAL OSHA AND HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AS WELL AS RECENT
LEGISLATION. WE HOPE
LEGISLATORS AND THE PUBLIC WILL
URGE THE STANDARDS BOARD TO
APPROVE THIS RULE. BUT THE
COMPANY T. S. WILL MEAN ITTLE
IF CALIFORNIANS HINDERED BY
VACANCIES IN A LIMITED ABILITY
TO MEET WORKERS WHERE THEY ARE.
I WAS TROUBLED TO SEE DIRECTOR
HAGEN RECENTLY TELL THE SENATE
COMMITTEE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
HAS ALL THE RESOURCES IT NEEDS.
CALIFORNIA WITH A WORKFORCE OF
NINETEEN MILLION AND OVER A
MILLION WORKPLACES HAS A
HUNDRED NINETY THREE INSPECTORS
AND DOZENS OF VACANCIES. THE
STATE HAS MORE FISHING GAME
WARDENS. WE NEED FULL STAFFING
OF CALIFORNIA NOT A PRI PAN
DEMICHELIS BETTER LEVEL
APPROPRIATE FOR TODAY'S THREATS
AND OPPORTUNITIES. CALIFORNIA'S
WORKERS MUST BE PROTECTED FROM
HAZARDS FOR THE LONG TERM. IN
CALIFORNIA HAS TO BE AT THE
TABLE AS DECISIONS ARE MADE TO
CONTROL AND CONTAIN THIS VIRUS.
BASED ON WHAT WE HEARD IN LAST
WEEK'S ADVISORY COMMITTEE
CAPACITY ISSUES ARE BEING TAKEN
SERIOUSLY. THE STATE LABOR
AGENCIES PARTNERSHIP WITH
WORKER ADVOCATES AND WAGING OUR
ENFORCEMENT ISA GREAT MODEL.
AND WORKSAFE IS REVIEWING
LEGISLATIVE IDEAS TO ENSURE
THAT THE AGENCY HAS ALL THE
AUTHORITY IT NEEDS TO SITE THE
LABOR CODE. AND ENFORCE A
WINDBREAKER RIGHT TO VIOLATED.
IN A GROSSLY INEQUITABLE GLOBAL
ECONOMY WE URGE LEGISLATORS AND
AGENCY TO DEMAND AND DEPLOY THE
RESOURCES AND TOOLS NECESSARY.
TO PROVIDE THE STATE'S
VULNERABLE WORKERS WITH THE
ENFORCEMENT OF PROTECTION THAT
WE ALL NEED. THANK YOU. YEAH
I'M A MISSILE FREEBIE BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. UHHUH
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CORINNE I'M
FREE AND I AM A STAFF ATTORNEY
AT WORK SAFE TODAY WILL BE
SPEAKING ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF LISTENING TO WORKERS AND THE
CRITICAL ROLE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS PLAY SINCE THE
START OF THE PANDEMIC. WHEN
DISASTERS STRIKE CALIFORNIA
LIKE RECENT WILDFIRES THE
CURRENT AND CURRENT PANDEMIC.
ORGANIZATIONS OF HAD TO PIVOT
TO MEET THE PRESSING DEMANDS OF
THEIR COMMUNITIES. RUSSERT'S
ORGANIZING HELPS KEEP WORKING
COMMUNITIES TOGETHER DURING
TIMES WHEN PEOPLE FEEL ISOLATED
AND UNHEARD. THIS IS NOT
MOTIVATED BY GOOD WELL ALONE
TOO OFTEN THESE EFFORTS ARE
NEEDED TO FILL GAPS IN SERVICES
CREATED BY UNDERSTAFFED AND
UNDER SOURCE RESOURCE STATE
AGENCIES LIKE CAL OSHA. THIS
HAS CERTAINLY BEEN THE CASE
WITH WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS AND
EDUCATION ORGANIZATIONS AND
COALITIONS HAVE STEPPED IN TO
SUPPORT WORKERS BY GIVING OUT
INFORMATION RESOURCES AND EVEN
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT WHEN THEY
HAVE THE CAPACITY TO DO SO.
THIS HAS BEEN NECESSARY IN THE
ABSENCE OF COMPREHENSIVE
ENFORCEMENT OF WORKPLACE HEALTH
AND SAFETY RIGHTS. SOMETIMES
THESE GROUPS ARE FILLING GAPS
CREATED BY NEGLIGENT EMPLOYERS
AS WELL THIS IS BEEN HAPPENING
DURING WILDFIRES WHEN
VOLUNTEERS HAD TO DISTRIBUTE
MASKS TO WORKERS WHO ARE NOT
GETTING THEM FROM THEIR
EMPLOYERS. COMMUNITY GROUPS
HAVE DEMONSTRATED HW POWERFUL
THEY ARE BY STEPPING INTO THIS
ROLE BUT THIS IS NOT THEIR
FUNCTION AND IT DEPLETES
LIMITED RESOURCES. TO BEGIN TO
ADDRESS THIS LONG STANDING
PROBLEM WORKERS CENTERS AND
OTHER WORKER ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE COMING
TOGETHER TO ENGAGE WITH CAL
OSHA LEADERSHIP AND A
SYSTEMATIZED WAY. THIS HELPS
BUILD TRUST IN THE AGENCY AT
THE GRASSROOTS LEVEL AND
ENABLES THE DIRECT FLOW OF
INFORMATION FROM WORKERS.
HOWEVER WITHOUT SUPPORT
COMMUNITY GROUPS ARE FEELING
EXHAUSTED. OUTRAGE EDUCATION
AND PARTNERSHIPS ARE ALWAYS
VALUABLE TOOLS AND THEY'RE
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL DURING A
PANDEMIC BUT RESOURCES ALSO
MUST BE ALLOCATED TO
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
CONNECTING WITH CAL OSHA. WE
ARE ENCOURAGED BY THE ADVENT OF
THE LABOR AGENCIES NEW OUTREACH
AND EDUCATION CAMPAIGNS IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE
PLAN TO FIND ORGANIZATIONS FOR
THEIR PARTICIPATION. THIS IS A
PIVOTAL CHANGE THAT WILL BUILD
TIES BETWEEN AGENCIES AND
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATIONS WE ARE
POSITIVE AND HOPEFUL THAT THIS
WILL LEAD TO SAFER WORKPLACES.
AT WORK SAVE WE HAVE SEEN THE
VALUE OF STRONG AGENCY
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS AFTER GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATION. BUILT TRUST WITH
JANITORIAL WORKERS WORKERS
FILED A HEALTH AND SAFETY
COMPLAINT FOR AN ARRAY OF OSHA
VIOLATIONS BECAUSE THE AGENCY
VALUED AND RESPECTED THE WORKER
AND ADVOCATES DURING THE
COMPLAINT PROCESS. WORKERS WERE
EMPOWERED THROUGH THIS PROCESS
ONE OF THE WORKERS HAS NOW
BECOME A PROMOTE DORA AND HER
COMMUNITY. THE BOTTOM LINE. IS
TO ACHIEVE WORKER SAFETY AND WE
NEED TO CENTER WORKERS VOICES
AND ENCOURAGE WORKER POWER.
SILENCED AND DISEMPOWERED
WORKERS WHO FEAR RETALIATION
AND LOSING THEIR JOBS OUR
WORKERS AT GREATER RISK OF
INJURY OR DEATH ON THE JOB.
THIS SUGGESTS WE NEED A STRONG
ANTI RETALIATION STATEMENT FROM
STATE LEADERS CALIFORNIA CANNOT
TOLERATE EMPLOYERS WHO
RETALIATE AGAINST WORKERS
REPORTING HAZARDS ARE
EXERCISING OTHER WORKPLACE
RIGHTS. AS MY COLLEAGUE STATED
THE CORONA VIRUS PANDEMIC IS
THE OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND
HEALTH CRISIS OF OUR LIFETIME.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO CONTINUE
ITS BOLD LEADERSHIP AND HEALTH
AND SAFETY WORKSAFE LOOKS
FORWARD TO PARTNERING WITH CAL
OSHA AS WE MOVE FORWARD TOWARDS
A SAFER CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
WORKERS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MISTER KNIGHT M. AND
THANK YOU TO WORK SAFE- FOR
YOUR WORK IN EMPOWERING AND
EDUCATING WORKERS THIS IS TRULY
REMARKABLE AND APPRECIATE IT.
AND- I'LL MAKE MENTION THE FACT
ONE OF MY APPRECIATION OF THE
GOVERNOR FOR. SIGNING MY BILL
TO HELP PROTECT WORKERS AGAINST
RETALIATION SO I THINK IT
SPEAKS TO THE- LAST POINT FROM
SOME PRETTY. I'M AND I'M GONNA
I'M GONNA I JUST WANNA ASK ONE
QUESTION OPENED UP TO EVERYONE
ELSE AND I HAVE A COUPLE MORE
LATER BUT- FOR MR ALAMO- MR
ALMOST ALEJO THANK YOU SO I
JUST HAD A QUICK QUESTION
TRYING TO LEAD THIS OFF- AS TO
WHETHER. WE HAVE ANY IDEA. BUT
THE INFECTION NUMBERS ARE IN
EACH INDUSTRY BECAUSE YOU CAN
GIVE A GOOD BREAK DOWN. OF
FRONTLINE WORKERS BY INDUSTRY-
MANY OF WHOM ARE LOW WAGE OR
LOWER WAGE WORKERS AND AS YOU
INDICATED IT'S ABOUT A THIRD OF
THE WORKFORCE SO DO WE HAVE ANY
IDEA WHAT THE INFECTION NUMBERS
ARE IN EACH INDUSTRY. TO OUR
KNOWLEDGE THERE THERE ISN'T YET
A STATEWIDE RESOURCE THAT WOULD
PROVIDE US THE INFORMATION
ABOUT INFECTION RATES BY
INDUSTRY OBVIOUSLY WE DO WISH
WE HAD- THAT KIND OF- DATA AS A
RESOURCE- IN RESPONDING TO THE
PANDEMIC- I WILL MENTION THAT
THAT IS. ONE OF THE COMPONENTS
OF AB SIX EIGHTY FIVE THAT WAS
DISCUSSED EARLIER- COMING INTO
THE NEW YEAR REQUIREMENTS THAT
LOCAL. COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS ARE COMMUNICATE THOSE
INFECTION RATES BY INDUSTRY TO
THE STATE TO HAVE THIS. SORT
OF- WRAPAROUND VIEW OF- THE
INFECTION RATE BY INDUSTRY BUT
THIS TIME THERE ARE SOME
COUNTIES THAT ARE REPORTING
THIS INFORMATION IN BITS AND
PIECES BUT WE WEREN'T ABLE TO
AGGREGATE A SUFFICIENT NUMBER
OF. DATA POINTS TO PROVIDE
SOMETHING TO THE COMMITTEE
TODAY. YOU KNOW I WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT AND I AND I
THINK THAT YOU SPEAK EXACTLY TO
MY POINT OF HOW GRATEFUL I AM
FOR AB SIX FIVE IN SOME AREAS.
NOW WE CAN ACTUALLY GET THAT
I'D GET INFO HAVE CONTINUITY
AND CONSISTENCY OF THE DATA
WE'RE GETTING STATEWIDE WHICH
OF COURSE DATA IS THE KEY- IN
COMBATING ANY ISSUES AT THE
WORK SITE PARTICULARLY WHEN IT
COMES TO. THE PANDEMICS OF
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I WANT
TO AGAIN EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO SOME AREAS. AB
SIXTY FIVE IN THE. GOVERNOR FOR
SIGNING IT INTO LAW. AND I ASK
HIM QUESTIONS IN THE LET ME ASK
IF ANYONE. OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OR ANY OF THE MEMBERS
HERE. BUT LIKE TO ASK ANY
QUESTIONS OR MAKE ANY COMMENTS.
AND WE DO HAVE HEROES OF A
ROBBERY THIS. IS HERE WITH US
AS WELL AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
WAS ON HIS WAY OVER. ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS THE SERVICE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA- ON PAGE. FOUR- IT HAS A
LIST OF VIOLATIONS AND
CITATIONS RELATED BUT NINETEEN.
ARE YOU BEFORE BECOMING AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I WAS AN
ATTORNEY AND REPRESENTED MANY
WORKERS COMPENSATION- INJURED
WORKERS AND I DO KNOW THAT
OFTENTIMES AN EMPLOYER WOULD
GET A CITATION BUT BY THE- TO.
THERE WAS VERY LITTLE THAT WAS
ACTUALLY PAID SO MY QUESTION
IS- OF THE CITATIONS THAT THE
ONE. MILLION DOLLARS IN
CITATIONS THAT ARE LISTED THERE
HOW MUCH WAS ACTUALLY COLLECTED.
I SHOULD POINT OUT MAYBE AT
THIS POINT THAT THESE CITATIONS
WERE ISSUED VERY RECENTLY ONLY
IN THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS- SO
COLLECTIONS HAVEN'T GONE
FORWARD I WOULD DEFER SPECIFICS
TO MISTER PARKER ON THOUGH I DO
KNOW THAT. THE EARLIEST GROUP
OF CITATIONS HAVE BEEN APPEALED
IN MOST CASES ALREADY ON THOSE
PEELS I BELIEVE ARE ARE STILL
OUTSTANDING GIVEN HOW RECENTLY-
THE CITATIONS WERE ISSUED.
FORGET IT- MISTER PARKER DID
YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO THAT OR
OR TO ADD TO THAT ANSWER. THAT
ANSWER IS CORRECT THESE ARE.
CAN YOU YES WE CAN THE THOSE
CASES ARE ALL STILL- EITHER ON
APPEAL BECAUSE THE EMPLOYER IS
CONTESTED THEM- ARE THEY'VE YET
TO BECOME FINAL ORDER CERTAINLY
ALL THE LARGER ONES THAT HAVE
BEEN CONTESTED SO WE WON'T KNOW
FOR AWHILE WHAT THE- FINAL
OUTCOMES ARE. I WILL ADD THAT
THE- THAT THE APPEALS BOARD
THAT HEARS THESE CASES THEY ARE
GOING TO BE EXPEDITING COVERT
NINETEEN CASES OF THEY WILL BE-
HIM MOVED TO THE FRONTLINE
ALONG WITH OTHER HIGH HIGHER
PRIORITY CASES. THANK YOU
RIGHT- THERE WAS MUCH
DISCUSSION AND ALSO IN THE
DOCUMENTS ARE PROVIDED TO US
ABOUT THE VACANCIES IN THE
VACANCY RATE OF 20% AND ADD TO
THE FACT THAT AS IT IS I READ
IT THERE WOULD BE YOU WILL
ATTEMPT TO FILL SIXTY FIVE
POSITIONS NOW AND ANOTHER
SEVENTY POSITIONS. IN THE
SPRING OF NEXT YEAR- HOW HAS
THIS AFFECTED YOUR ABILITY AT
ENFORCEMENT. TO HAVE SUCH A
SUCH A HIGH VACANCY RATE. SO TO
HAVE A GREAT. WELL IT CERTAINLY
HAS AN IMPACT- BECAUSE WE HAVE
FEWER PEOPLE TO DO THE WORK WE
HAVE TO- PULL INSPECTORS INTO
THE OFFICE TO CONDUCT-
ADMINISTRATIVE DUTIES IF WE
DON'T YOU KNOW IF WE HAVE
TEMPORARY SHORTAGES OF A OF
ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF DID A-
VACANCY RATES ARE EVER YOU KNOW
IF THE VACANCY RATE IS LOW AND
THEN WE HAVE. AN ABSENCE THEN
YOU KNOW SOME OF THAT CRITICAL
WORK STILL HAS TO BE DONE- SO
IT DOES DEFINITELY HAS AN
IMPACT IT HAS MORE IMPACT IN
SOME PLACES THAN OTHERS IT JUST
DEPENDS ON WHAT HE- STAFFING
LEVELS ARE IN- THOSE PARTICULAR
PARTS OF THE STATE- HELP YOU
AND THERE'S ALSO JUST THE ISSUE
OF WHAT THE- MIX OF EXPERTISE
IS WITHIN A PARTICULAR OFFICE
SO- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT IN THESE
CASES IS TO HAVE PEOPLE WITH. A
HEALTH EXPERTISE- AND SO
THAT'S- THAT'S BEEN A- A SKILL
SET THAT WE'VE LOST OVER THE
YEARS AND SOMETHING THAT I
HAVE- COMMITTED TO- IMPROVING
EVEN BEFORE COVERED AND SO
WE'VE CONVERTED A NUMBER OF OUR
SAFETY CAN- POSITIONS TO
INDUSTRIAL HYGIENE POSITIONS
ARE ACTIVELY RECRUITING.
NATIONALLY FOR THOSE- TO FILL
THOSE JOBS AND WE'VE HAD VERY
GOOD RESULTS IN TERMS OF THE
FOLKS THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
RECRUIT AND HAVE APPLIED TO
THOSE POSITIONS. PLEASE WALK US
THROUGH. THE BUDGET INCLUDED
THE FUNDING FOR ALL OF THESE
POSITIONS. WHAT GOES THROUGH.
SO THAT I CAN BETTER UNDERSTAND
HOW IT'S POSSIBLE TO HAVE SO
MANY VACANCIES WHEN YOU HAVE
THE MONEY TO FILL THEM. THE-
THE ISSUE OF VACANCIES AS ONE
THAT IS- BEEN AN ISSUE FOR SOME
TIME IT CALIPHATE PRECEDES MY-
MY APPOINTMENT TO BE THE CHIEF-
IT BEGAN WITH A REVIEW IS
YOU'RE PROBABLY FAMILIAR WITH
WITH THE- STATE PERSONNEL BOARD
IN THE STATE AUDITOR. WHICH
CONCLUDED THAT THERE WAS A NEED
TO REVAMP THE HIRING PROCESS
AND SORT OF RE LEARN
APPROPRIATE MERIT BASED HIRING
PROCESSES AT DR GENERALLY-
INCLUDING CALLOSUM. AND SO
WE'VE BEEN IN AN EXTENSIVE
REBUILDING PROCESS FOR SOME
TIME TO- WE TRAIN OUR STAFF ON
HIRING PROCESSES TO RE WRITE
DUTY STATEMENTS TO- WE LEARN-
THESE PROCESSES AND- THE EFFECT
OF HAVING TO. BUT SO MANY
HIRING- PACKAGES THROUGH THE
PROCESS ALL AT ONCE- IT
CERTAINLY IS- IS BEEN A STRAIN
ON THE SYSTEM AND IT'S BEEN AN
ONGOING LEARNING PROCESS. WE
ARE- SEEN RESULTS NOW IT TAKES
SOME TIME BUT WE ARE DEFINITELY
SEEING RESULTS AND MAKING THOSE
HIRES- IT IS CERTAINLY
FRUSTRATING FOR ME AS HEAD OF
THIS. DIVISION HAVING
RESPONSIBILITY- BOTH
PROFESSIONALLY AND FEELING A
GREAT PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY
TO THESE WORKERS WHO ARE
EXPOSED TO THESE HAZARDS- TO
SEE THAT GAP MYSELF BETWEEN
THE- BUDGET THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE FOR STAFF AND THE-
AND THE LIMITS ON THE STAFF
THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE TO SEND
OUT IN THE FIELD. I WOULD.
SUGGEST COMMUNITY COLLEGES OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CAN TAILOR
THEIR TRAINING TO THE NEEDS I
WOULD HIGHLY RECOMMEND THAT
THAT BE USED. IF I MAY ON THE
FIRST PAGE OF THE BACKGROUND
BRIEF THAT YOU PROVIDED TO US.
YOU TALKED ABOUT A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE IN THE DEMAND FOR
ENFORCEMENT AS A RESULT OF
COVERT NINETEEN- AND YOU'RE SET
FOR FEBRUARY ONE TO THE END OF
OCTOBER YOU HAD TWELVE THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT
COMPLAINTS. I PERHAPS I MISSED
IT IN THE DOCUMENTS BUT I
DIDN'T SEE WHAT THAT COMPARED
TO LAST YEAR THE YEAR BEFORE.
THERE'S AN INCREASE BUT GIVE US
A BETTER IDEA WHAT WHAT WHAT
KIND OF INCREASES THAT. WHAT WE
NORMALLY HAVE- TEN TO TWELVE
THOUSAND COMPLAINTS IN A YEAR
SO- I BELIEVE BY THE END OF
OCTOBER THIRTY FIRST. WE HAD
EXCEEDED THIRTEEN THOUSAND
TOTAL COMPLAINTS SINCE.
FEBRUARY ONE- AND ABOUT EIGHT
THOUSAND OF THOSE WERE COVERED
NINETEEN RELATED- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THAT
COMPLAINTS ARE NOT THE ONLY
SOURCE OF OUR WORKLOAD WE ALSO.
HAVE A STATUTORY MANDATE TO
INVESTIGATE SERIOUS ILLNESSES
THAT ARE REPORTED. AND
FATALITIES THAT ARE REPORTED-
SO WE'VE HAD- AS OF OCTOBER
THIRTY FIRST TO SIX HUNDRED
FORTY FATALITIES REPORTED TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY OF THOSE WERE
COVERED NINETEEN RELATED AT
LEAST AS THEY WERE REPORTED
AND- FOUR THOUSAND OVER FOUR
THOUSAND SERIOUS INJURIES AND
ILLNESSES OF WHICH THOUSAND ARE
COVERED RELATED. AS WELL AS A
NUMBER OF REFERRALS AND OTHER-
OTHER ACTIVITIES THAT HAVE
TRIGGERED INSPECTION SUCH AS
MEDIA REPORTS AND REPORTS FROM
OTHER AGENCIES SO- IT IS ONE
PART OF OUR- OUR WORKLOAD. AND
I JUST WANT TO MAKE A COMMENT
REGARDING THE INVESTIGATIONS TO
SENDING OUT A LETTER AS OPPOSED
TO IN PERSON INVESTIGATIONS.
CAUSES GREAT CONCERN FOR ME-
IT'S YOU GET A LETTER IT'S LIKE
A SLAP ON THE WRIST- AS OPPOSED
TO HAVING AN IN PERSON.
INVESTIGATION BY CAL OSHA THAT
WAS ALWAYS IT WAS ALWAYS A BIG
DEAL AND IT SHOULD BE A BIG
DEAL- I JUST WANTED TO MAKE
THAT COMMENT AND IF I MAY
MISTER CHAIR- TO. TO STEVEN
KNIGHT AND CORINNE I'M FREE.
CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW. I WANT TO.
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK YOU DO.
YOUR WORK IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT HAVING ADVOCATES FOR
WORKERS- HAVING IT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT NINETEEN MILLION
WORKERS AND THAT THE FACT THAT
THE FACT THAT YOU PROVIDED TO
US. HELP TREMENDOUSLY AS WE ARE
EVALUATING WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE WITHIN THE AGENCY BUT GETS
UP WITH THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA KNOWING HOW WE TAKE
CARE OF OUR WORKERS. ESPECIALLY
OUR FRONT LINE WORKERS SO I DO
WANT TO THANK YOU AND MS I'M
FREE FOR THE WORK THAT YOU DO-
AND ALSO APPRECIATE VERY MUCH
THE COMMENT FROM IS ON FREE.
ABOUT LISTENING TO THE WORKERS
I APPRECIATE THAT THE CHAIR HAS
INCLUDED THAT IN TODAY'S
HEARING THAT WE WILL HEAR FROM
THE WORKERS BUT I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WORK. THANK YOU.
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER SO- YEAH
THANK YOU SOME AREAS AND MISTER
KNIGHT WHILE YOU WHILE WE HAVE-YOU HERE- ALSO ONE EXPRESSED
APPRECIATION AND- YOU SPOKE TO
AS WELL AS- YES I'M PRETTY
ABOUT THE ART REGION EDUCATION
ASPECT AND- AND FRANKLY I THINK
SHE- SHE RECEIVED MENTION
ABOUT. THE THAT SHE'S A TRUMP
FEELING EXHAUSTED I THINK
THAT'S LIKE P. TWENTY TWENTY
THEY WERE ALL KIND OF WINGS
OFSTED JUST. TRYING TRYING TO
DO EVERYTHING THAT WE CAN
ESPECIALLY AS IT APPLIES. TO
ANSWERING THE WORKERS THAT ARE
ALLOWING SO MANY OF US. TO STAY
AT HOME. WITH OUR FAMILIES- IT
AS RUBY ASKED TO. CAN DO THAT
IS BECAUSE OF THESE WORKERS
AND- MR NIGHT OF A QUESTION. OR
OR MAYBE. MORE OF A KIND OF
STRATEGICALLY. HOW DO YOU SEE.
EDUCATION OUTREACH LIKE. THAT
THAT WOULD BE MOST AFFECTED
EFFECTIVE. IN FACILITATING
WORKER AWARENESS AND ENSURING
EMPLOYEE COMPLIANCE AND- THEY
AND I KNOW THERE'S A WIDE RANGE
WORKERS BUT- SPEAKING
SPECIFICALLY FOR EXAMPLE TO
FARMWORKERS AND- WITH THE- SOME.
DE AB TWENTY THREE A HAS
DIFFERENT TYPES OF REQUIREMENTS
IN TERMS OF OUT REACH. WHAT DO
YOU FEEL WOULD BE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE USE OF THE I CAN
GUESS YOU SEE THIS NEW TOOL-
NOT ON THE GROUND BECAUSE YOU
KNOW WE DO LEGISLATION HERE
MISS RESURGENT. BUT ON THE JOB
ALL THE PACKAGE OF BILLS TO DO
NOT REACH A FARMWORKERS AND BUT
WHAT WHAT DO YOU HOW DO YOU SEE
IT PLAYING OUT. IN REAL TIME
OVER THE NEXT FEW MONTHS BUT
COME JANUARY TO JANUARY FIRST.
I NEED TO HEAD THINK THERE'S
JUST NO SUBSTITUTE FOR
RESOURCES AND- PARTNERING WITH
TRUSTED COMMUNITY ADVOCATES-
AND THAT IS YOU KNOW THE WORK
THAT. THE WORKSAFE FACILITATES
WITH THE BROAD COALITIONS THAT
HAVE COME TOGETHER. AROUND- ALL
OF OUR INITIATIVES- SO- YOU
KNOW THE SURVEY FROM TOWARD-
AND EXAMPLES THE WORK THAT'S
BEEN DONE AROUND THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT TO- TO MEET- AND LIFT
UP COMMUNITY LEADERS AND- REACH
PEOPLE. THROUGH AVENUES AND
LOOK IN LANGUAGES THAT THEY-
CAN- WHERE THEY CAN BE MET AND
IT'S JUST NO REAL SUBSTITUTE
FOR THIS THE HARD WORK THE
RESOURCES THE SHOE OTHER- THE-
THE PARTNERSHIPS- THAT ARE
ALREADY THERE- THE EXIST BUT
THEY ARE FRAGILE AND UNDER A
LOT OF STRESS. AS CORINNE- VERY
ELOQUENTLY ALREADY TESTIFIED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- AS A MEMBER
RIVAS DID YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR THIS
FOR ANYONE ON THIS PANEL. I
DON'T BUT I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE RESPONSES AND- YOU KNOW.
SURE THAT WE UNDERSTAND- THE
PROCESS BEFORE BECAUSE CREDIT
WE POINT TO- A LOT OF- OUR
CONSTITUENTS IN THE WORK THAT
WE DID LAST YEAR. THANK YOU AND
I DON'T WANNA. EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO THE FIRST
PATENT THIS FIRST PANEL FOR THE
WORLD YOU'RE ALL DOING
INFORMATION PROVIDING US AND
AGAIN PLEASE REACH OUT TO THE
COMMITTEE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OTHER MEMBERS AS A RESOURCE
ESPECIALLY THERE ARE THINGS
THAT YOU THINK THAT WE NEED TO
BE OING THAT WE'RE NOT DOING.
OF BUDGET POLICY OTHER THINGS
THAT YOU NEED TO AND WE HEARD
FROM MISTER PARKER YOU KNOW
WITH OSHA WE ARE ALL FANS OF
OSHA AND THE ABILITY FOR OSHA
TO BE ABLE TO DO ITS WORK NOT
AS A WAY OF PUNISHING EMPLOYERS
BUT AS A WAY OF EDUCATING
EMPLOYERS AND MAKING SURE
THEY'RE DOING EVERYTHING THEY
CAN. TO SUPPORT WORKERS WE ALL
HAVE TO BE ON THE SAME TEAM
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS PANDEMIC
AND SO. I APPRECIATE- EVERYONE
ON THIS PLAN. FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK. WITH ALL
OF YOU- BUT IT AND THE
CONTINUING CHALLENGES. BOB
WE'RE GONNA BE SEEING IN THE
MONTHS AHEAD. SO THANK YOU ALL
TO THE UP TO OUR FIRST PANEL-
ACTUALLY. THE MACHINE I TAKE
THAT BACK IF THERE'S ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINES AT ONCE A CALL
ASKING QUESTIONS. MAKING
COMMENTS. I THINK WE HAVE- VICE
CHAIR FLORA. FOR ANYONE IF NOT
THAT'S FINE BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE WE GET THE OPPORTUNITY.
BEFORE I MOVE ON. OKAY AND ALL
THE MEMBERS HAVE YOU KNOW THAT
THEY HAVE MYSELF ON THE CONTAX
MEAN FOR SOME REASON. IT'S NOT
GETTING THROUGH FEEL FREE TO DO
THAT MY PHONES RIGHT HERE. I'M
PAYING ATTENTION TO IT TO MAKE
SURE I'M NOT MISSING ANYONE-
BUT- I KNOW THAT WILL HAVE.
MEMBERS TUNING IN AT VARIOUS
TIMES AND I KNOW ALSO THAT- THE
PRESENTATION ITSELF IS
WORTHWHILE AND- THERE MAY NOT
BE FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. FROM MEMBERS THAT ARE
TUNING AND REMOTELY. SO- OKAY
SO THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH FOR
THE FIRST PANEL. WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE SECOND PANEL IN
FIGURE WAS SOMETHING THAT- MISS
I'M FREE SAID THE IMPORTANCE OF
LISTENING TO WORKERS AND THAT'S
WHAT. THE SECOND PANEL IS
ABOUT- WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO THE SECOND PANEL FRONT LINE
WORKERS FROM FOR. INDUSTRIES.
AND FIRST UP- AND I'LL JUST
INTRODUCE THE FALL YOU SEE HERE.
OKAY YES- FIRST UP- WE WILL BE
HEARING FROM. OR WILL GETTING
AN OVERVIEW OF THE BROKER
PERSPECTIVE FROM MID STEIGER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WHO HAS UP TO SIX
MINUTES SO WHEN WE GO AHEAD AND
START WITH MITCH WHENEVER HE'S
READY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MITCH DYER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY THE COCA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC PRESENTS A LOT OF
CHALLENGES THAT ARE. IN MANY
WAYS UNIQUE AND SOMETHING THAT
NONE OF US HAVE EVER SEEN IN
OUR LIFETIMES BUT IN OTHER WAYS
IT'S REALLY JUST AN INTENSIFIED
MORE VISIBLE VERSION OF WHAT
WORKERS ALWAYS FACE IN TRYING
TO STAY SAFE ON THE JOB. WE'VE
SEEN A VARIETY OF EMPLOYER
RESPONSES FROM SOME THAT DO
EVERYTHING THAT THEY CAN AND
EVERYTHING THAT THEY KNOW OF TO
KEEP WORKERS SAFE BUT- FOR
EVERYONE OF THOSE THERE'S AN
EMPLOYER THAT. DOES LITTLE TO
NOTHING THAT EVEN GOES BEYOND
THAT TO SHAME WORKERS WHO TRY
TO STAY SAFE THREE PP OR MASKS
OR EVEN RETALIATE AGAINST THOSE
WHO REPORT HAZARDS OR GET SICK
ON THE JOB. WHICH LEADS US ALL
TO RELY ON CALLOW SHOW AND THE
LABOR MOVEMENT AND GROUPS LIKE
WORKSAFE ENCOURAGES INDIVIDUALS
TO PROTECT WORKERS WHERE
EMPLOYERS WANT. AND TO FOCUS ON
CALIFORNIA FOR A SECOND THE
ISSUE OF STAFFING HAS BEEN
MENTIONED A LOT AND THAT'S
REALLY ONE THAT WE SEE AS THE
PRIORITY HERE THAT THE 20%
VACANCY RATE. HAS BEEN A PRETTY
STUBBORN ISSUE AT LEAST AS LONG
AS WE'VE BEEN PAYING ATTENTION
TO WHAT THE 20% RATE HAS BEEN
THERE FOR AT LEAST A DECADE
DESPITE THE BEST EFFORTS OF
VARIOUS AGENCY HEADS AND THAT'S
DEFINITELY ENCOURAGING TO HEAR
THAT. THERE REMAINS A FOCUS AND
HOPEFULLY THIS TIME WE CAN MAKE
SOME SIGNIFICANT STEPS TOWARDS
SOLVING IT BUT WE THINK IT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO GET A
LITTLE BIT INTO THE WEEDS OF
EXACTLY WHAT THAT LACK OF
STAFFING. NEEDS FOR WORKERS AND
THE PRIMARY PROBLEM THAT IT
CAUSES IS AS WAS MENTIONED A
FOCUS ON LETTER INVESTIGATIONS
AS OPPOSED TO ONSITE
INSPECTIONS. AND JUST SOME
QUICK NUMBERS IN NINETEEN
NINETY TWO QALISYA CONDUCTED
TWELVE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY INSPECTIONS IN
PERSON INSPECTIONS AND ONLY
SENT EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY
EIGHT LETTERS. LAST YEAR BEFORE
CODE NINETEEN EVER- IT
CALIFORNIA THERE WERE SEVENTY
HOUSE FIVE HUNDRED. INTO AND
OVER SEVEN THOUSAND LETTERS
THAT WERE SENT. SO WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE CHART THAT MAPS OUT
HOW MANY THAT DON'T EACH YEAR
YOU CAN SEE IT KIND OF DOING
THIS. AND IT'S GOTTEN TO A
POINT EVEN BEFORE COVERT
NINETEEN HAPPENED. WHERE THEY
WERE DOING ABOUT THE SAME%
NUMBER OF LETTERS AS ONSITE
INSPECTIONS AND IS ONSITE
INSPECTIONS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THAT. AN EXPERT FROM
CALIFORNIA IS THERE IN PERSON
THEY ASKED TO SEE THE INJURY
ILLNESS PREVENTION PLAN THEY
ASKED TO SEE THE FORM THREE
HUNDRED. THEY GET A REALLY GOOD
SENSE OF JUST HOW BAD THINGS
ARE AT THAT EMPLOYER AND YOU
CAN SEE IF THERE ARE ANYTHING
IF THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE GOING
WRONG. YOU JUST DON'T GET THAT
WITH THE LETTER INVESTIGATION
AND THOUGH THE LETTERS ARE ARE
DEFINITELY NOT USELESS THEY DO
DO SOMETHING WE NEED TO SEE
MORE ON SITE INSPECTIONS.
ESPECIALLY WITH COCA NINETEEN
TO MAKE SURE THAT WORKERS ARE
KEPT SAFE. AND IT ALSO REALLY
AFFECTS THE- THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF THINGS LIKE THE COVER
NINETEEN STANDARD THAT'S UP FOR
THE STANDARDS BOARD ON
THURSDAY. THEN IT'S A GREAT
STANDARD IT'S A VERY WELL
WRITTEN. WE VERY MUCH HOPE THE
STANDS FOR DISAPPROVAL. BUT
WHILE IT DOES GIVE EMPLOYERS
MORE CLEARLY AS FAR AS WHAT
THEY NEED TO DO TO KEEP WORKERS
SAFE. IT WILL GENERATE A LOT OF
COMPLAINTS I WOULD JUST KIND
OF. GO ON THE PILE OF
COMPLAINTS THE COLORS SHE JUST
DOESN'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
DEAL WITH. AND IN THAT SENSE.
IT REALLY IS GOING TO BE LESS
EFFECTIVE THAN IT COULD BE IF
WE DID HAVE THE STAFFING THAT
WAS NECESSARY. ALSO WANTED TO
MENTION THAT IN RECENT YEARS
EMPLOYER APPEALS OF CITATIONS.
HAVE REALLY GOTTEN OUT OF
CONTROL. AND THAT HAS LED A LOT
OF INSPECTORS TO HAVE TO DO ALL
SORTS OF PAPERWORK. WHEN THEY
DO MORE SERIOUS CITATION
SERIOUS WILL FOR. ONCE IN ORDER
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE CITATION
CAN SURVIVE THE LEGAL
CHALLENGE. AND SO THAT'S
ANOTHER FACTOR IN THE MINDS OF
THE INSPECTOR WHEN THEY'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
RESPOND TO SOMETHING THAT. HAS
BEEN REPORTED. THAT IF THEY DO
THIS AS AN IN PERSON
INSPECTION. THEY'VE GOT TO
SPEND A LOT OF TIME FILLING OUT
PAPERWORK THAT'S TIME THAT THEY
COULD BE SPENDING DOING
SOMETHING ELSE MAYBE SENDING
LETTERS MAYBE INSPECTING OR
DANGER SUPPORT. SO IT'S NOTHING
THAT PUTS HIM IN AN IMPOSSIBLE
POSITION THAT LIMITS HOW WELL
THEY CAN KEEP WORKERS SAFE.
THERE'S ALSO AN ISSUE WHERE
MANY INSPECTORS ARE COMFORTABLE
DOING IN PERSON INSPECTIONS. SO
WE NEED TO WE NEED TO DO A LOT
TO MAKE SURE THAT. THOSE
INSPECTORS HAVE THE TRAINING
AND THE PP THEY NEED TO KEEP
WORKERS SAFE. ALL OF WHICH KIND
OF ADDS UP TO A DEMORALIZING
EXPERIENCE FOR A LOT OF
INSPECTORS THAT. IT STANDS TO
REASON THAT DEMORALIZE WORKERS
ARE LESS LIKELY TO STAY AT THE
JOB AND SO THAT'S GOING TO
INTENSIFY THE STAFFING
STRUGGLES. BUT IT'S NOT ALL
ABOUT CAL OSHA ANOTHER BIG
PROBLEM WE SEE WRITING OVER ALL
OF THIS IS THAT. FRANKLY NOT
ENOUGH WORKERS ARE IN UNIONS.
AND BEING IN A UNION CAN BE
PRETTY DECISIVE IN DETERMINING.
WHETHER OR NOT. YOU WAS A
WORKER EVEN ABLE TO SURVIVE
THIS PANDEMIC. WORKERS IN
UNIONS AS YOU'RE ABOUT TO HEAR
FROM THE NEXT WITNESSES- HAVE
THE BENEFIT OF ALL SORTS OF
INTERVENTIONS FROM THINGS LIKE.
A UNION HELPING TO ENSURE
IMMEDIATE COMPLIANCE WITH
EXISTING RAGS AND GUIDANCES.
PROVIDING PP WHEN EMPLOYERS
WANT TO EDUCATING WORKERS ON
THEIR RIGHTS. AND A LOT OF
OTHER STUFF THAT A UNION CAN
TAKE TO HELP PROTECT WORKERS.
BUT WITHOUT A UNION. WHEN A
COMPLAINT IS FILED. K. OFF GOES.
THE TO GET A LIST OF WORKERS TO
TALK TO. OBVIOUSLY THE
EMPLOYER. IS NOT GOING TO PICK
THE VOCAL ACTIVIST TYPES THAT
ARE COMPLAINING ABOUT THE
HAZARDS ARE GOING TO PICK THE
ONES THAT ARE. LESS LIKELY TO
DO THAT. AND SO THEY'RE GOING
TO GIVE A DIFFERENT
INTERPRETATION OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING TO THE INSPECTOR.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE THE SYSTEM IS
KIND OF DESIGNED TO. DOWNPLAY
THE SEVERITY OF THE HAZARD AND
THAT'S SOMETHING ELSE THAT'S
GOING TO HELP THE PANDA
EXPRESS. HELP WORK HELP MORE
WORKERS GET THE VIRUS AND PUT
US ALL IN A WORSE POSITION.
ALSO WITHOUT A UNION WORKERS
ARE HARLEM WHOLE LOT MORE
LIKELY TO WIND UP
MISCLASSIFIED. AND OBVIOUSLY
MISCLASSIFIED WORKERS HAVE NO
CAL OSHA PROTECTIONS AT ALL.
BUT BY AND LARGE. THE PIPE BY
FAR THE BIGGEST ISSUE THAT-
THAT'S AT THE TOP WORK HERE IS
THAT WORKERS. AREN'T IN UNIONS.
HAVE LITTLE IF ANY PROTECTIONS
AGAINST RETALIATION. THAT THERE
IS IT IS OBVIOUSLY ILLEGAL TO
RETALIATE AGAINST WORKERS FOR
REPORTING HEALTH AND SAFETY
HAZARDS BUT- THE REALITY IS
THAT IT TAKES SO LONG TO
PROCESS THESE CASES. THAT MOST
WORKERS. YOU KNOW IF THEY GET
FIRED FOR REPORTING SOMETHING
THEY STAY FIRED FOR YEARS IF
EVEN IF THEY DO STAY INVOLVED
WITH THE CLAIM. AND MOST OF THE
TIME THEY NEED TO GET A NEW JOB
AND THEY JUST MOVE ON. AND
THAT'S WHAT WE THINK IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING TO DEAL
WITH AND- ON THAT FRONT. SO
BOTH SHORT AND LONG TERM. JUST
ONE OF THE CLOSE BY SAYING WE
DON'T REALLY THINK IT WHATEVER
SOLUTIONS WE COME UP WITH
WHATEVER NEW STANDARDS OR NEW
PROTECTIONS. NOTHING IS GOING
TO WORK VERY WELL WITHOUT THREE
THINGS. ONE MORE STAFFING AT
CAL OSHA. TWO MORE IN PERSON
INSPECTIONS AND THREE OF MORE
WORKERS AND UNIONS. WE'RE DOING
ALL WE CAN IN THE THIRD ONE AND
WE DEFINITELY STAND READY AND
COMMITTED TO HELP. HELPING ALL
STAKEHOLDERS EVERYONE IN THIS
BUILDING HELP MAKE SURE THAT.
WE SAW THE FIRST ONES AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE SO THAT WE CAN. GET
OUT OF THIS PANDEMIC AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR STEINER- INVOLVED WILL
HOLD FOR QUESTIONS AT THE END
OF THE PANEL. AFTER EVERYONE
HAS A CHANCE TO SPEAK AND SO
THAT YOU CAN HANG UP THAT BE
GREAT- AND SO WE HAVE FOUR.
SECTORS WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING
FINAL GONNA START WITH
AGRICULTURE. AND WHAT WE'RE
GONNA DO IS I BELIEVE. THAT
MISTER FERNANDEZ WANTS TO GO
FOR A IS GONNA BE GOING FIRST-
AIRBENDER FERNANDEZ BUT I ALSO
BELIEVE OR BEEN TOLD THAT WE
MAY NOT HAVE DIRECT IMMEDIATE
TRANSLATION FOR MISS AYE
DOLLARS OVER GOING TO DO IS.
WE'RE GONNA GO TO ALBERTO
FERNANDEZ A STRATEGIC CAMPAIGN
COORDINATOR WITH YOU HAVE W.
THE UNITED FARM WORKERS
FOUNDATION AND THEN RE OCULAR A
WORKER REPRESENTATIVE- SO WE
HEAR FROM FROM FROM- MISS
OCULAR. AND THEN- AFTER
RECYCLER SPEAKS WILL GO BACK TO
MISTER FERNANDEZ TO TRANSLATE-
THE STATEMENT FROM- MISS OCULAR
SO WHAT IS A BACK AND FORTH A
LITTLE BIT AS I WAS ON THE
PHONE BUT AS WE CAN SEE HERE IN
THE ROOM. MISTER FERNANDEZ IS
ON THE SCREEN SO- PLEASE MISS
FERNANDEZ ONCE GO AHEAD AS A
TOTAL OF EIGHT MINUTES AND
OBVIOUSLY HAVE THAT CUSHION.
FOR TRANSITION TIME AS WELL.
THANK YOU GERMAN CAR LIKE GOOD
AFTERNOON. I'M A BIT OF A NON
THERE'S A SET OF FARMWORKERS
AND AN ADVOCATE WITH THE UFW
FOUNDATION. IT IS SAID THAT
CRISIS HIGHLIGHTS THE BEST AND
WORST IN PEOPLE. THIS IS AS
TRUE FOR PEOPLE AS IT IS FOR
LEADERS AND OUR STATE AS A
WHOLE. FARMWORKERS SEE THE
PANDEMIC AS SHEDDING LIGHT ON A
TALE OF TWO CALIFORNIA'S. THERE
ARE FARMWORKERS AND THEN
THERE'S A CALIFORNIA FOR ALL.
CALIFORNIA IS A LEADING
AGRICULTURAL STATE IN THE
NATION AND IS HOME TO THE
LARGEST NUMBER OF FARMWORKERS
AND BY THESE NUMBERS YOU WOULD
THINK THAT CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURE IS FLOURISHING. IT
IS IT IS FLOURISHING BUT JUST
NOT FOR FARMWORKERS HERE THE
FAX FARMWORKERS ARE
UNDOCUMENTED AND IN THE STATE
THEY DON'T QUALIFY FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FOR
PERMANENT PAID SICK LEAVE OR
FOR CALIFORNIA FOR ALL HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE. FARMWORKERS ARE
NOT CONSIDERED FOR STATE HAZARD
PAY DESPITE WORKING IN ONE OF
THE MOST DANGEROUS JOBS IN THE
COUNTRY. MANY FARMWORKERS ARE
PAID UNDER THE TABLE AND
CHEATED OUT OF THEIR WAGES. AND
THEN WHEN WE CONTINUE TO ALLOW
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA TO SHUT
DOWN AND START OVER WHEN THEY
REFUSED TO PAY. UNDER THE H.
TWO A. VISA PROGRAM GUEST
WORKERS ARE INDENTURED SERVANTS
AND THE STATE'S HOUSING CODE
STILL ALLOWS FOR BARRACKS STYLE
HOUSING TO SET TO BE SUBSIDIZED
AND TO SUBSIDIZE YOUR PRESSION
OF PEOPLE. WHILE PERFORMING
BACKBREAKING WORK TO FEED THE
NATION FARMWORKERS ARE EXPOSED
TO EXTREME HEAT PESTICIDES TO
THE RISK OF KOBE NINETEEN AND
TO THE HARMFUL AIR. DUE TO THE
WILDFIRES. THEY WORK IN
EVACUATION ZONES WITH NO MASKS
IN THE NAME OF SAVING COMMODITY
FROM THE FIRE WHILE MANY STILL
FACE FOOD INSECURITY AT HOME.
NOW YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF
WITH ALL THE PUBLIC STATEMENTS
ABOUT WHAT HAS BEEN DONE FOR
FARMWORKERS WHY ARE THE STILL
THE FAX AS WE SIT HERE TODAY.
WHY IS THERE SO MUCH DISPARITY
IN POWER DISPARITY IN INCOME
DISPARITY IN HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. DISPARITY IN WORKING
CONDITIONS AND DISPARITY AND
THE LAWS THAT GOVERN OUR STATE
AGRICULTURAL SYSTEM. LIKE OTHER
HISTORIC INJUSTICES THE SYSTEM
IS NOT BROKEN RATHER THE
AGRICULTURAL SYSTEM IS DESIGNED
TO KEEP FARMWORKERS FROM EVER
RECEIVING THE ECONOMIC
RECOGNITION THEY DESERVE. WE
OFFER THE FOLLOWING FARMWORKERS
NEED CHANGES IN THE EXISTING
STATE PROCESS FOR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING ELECTIONS SO THAT
WHEN FARMWORKERS ORGANIZED THEY
CAN LIFT THEMSELVES UP AND
NEGOTIATE FOR THEMSELVES. THE
CURRENT VOTING AND ELECTION
PROCESS IS MEANT TO SUPPRESS
VOTES AND THE NIGHT OUTCOMES
ALL TO PERPETUATE THE ECONOMIC
OPPRESSION THAT HAS EXISTED
SINCE THE EARLY DAYS OF SLAVERY.
IT MUST CHANGE AND WE SHOULD BE
LEADING THE CHANGE TO CHANGE IT.
ADDITIONALLY FARMWORKERS ARE
CONSISTENTLY WRITTEN OUT OF
STATE LAWS THAT LEADERS
THEMSELVES NEGOTIATE WE NEED
LEADERS THAT WILL PRIORITIZE
HUMANS AS MUCH AS A PRIORITIZE
COMMODITIES. THAT WON'T ALLOW
WORKERS TO BE UNPROTECTED WHILE.
KING GRAPES IN FIRE ZONES. THAT
WILL REVIEW THE STATE LAWS THAT
THEY'RE NEGOTIATING AND ASK
THEMSELVES IF THESE LAWS WORK
FOR FARMWORKERS AND LEADERS WHO
WILL ENFORCE CURRENT LAWS AND
ENSURE FINES ARE COLLECTED NOT
JUST ISSUED. THE ESSENTIAL
WORKER DESIGNATION DOES NOT
MEAN THAT FARMWORKERS GET MORE
PROTECTIONS. THE AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY HAS RECEIVED BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN KOBE NINETEEN
LEGISLATION YET FARMWORKERS ARE
STILL WITING FOR MASKS.
WAITING FOR SAFE SOCIAL
DISTANCING PRACTICES AT WORK
WAITING FOR BASIC SANITATION
SUPPLIES AND FOR KOBE NINETEEN
SCREENINGS AND FOR PORTABLE
BATHROOMS TO BE CLEANED. WE
HOPE YOU CAN JOIN US AS WE LOOK
TO CHANGE THE SYSTEMIC
INJUSTICES BUILT IN OUR
EXISTING LAWS AND THAT YOU
THINK OF US WHEN YOU WRITE THE
NEXT STATE SET OF LAWS THAT
IMPACT FARMWORKERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HI MISTER FERNANDEZ- WILL HEAR
ON THE PHONE FROM HER MARIA I
DO A LOT. ONE OF. THE NUMBER OF
NINETY AGGIE LAST. YOU'LL BE
ONE MORE THAN A KIND OF IF YOU
LOOK UP IF YOU'RE NOT BORDERS
IRAN OVER CAMPBELLTOWN MOP THE
ITEM IN OFTEN. I'M DONALD PETER
PETER TO COME. ONE OF THE ONE
MILLION PROGRAM MENTAL UP FRONT
PANEL SIX AT THE END OF BUT I
WANT NINETY SOME AT THE PROTECT
IT COMES THEN PHONE BACK
DIRECTLY CAN ORDER. IF I THAT
WILL BE A FOCUS JENNIFER OF
THAT IS DIRECT MOBILE THEM UP
THE ADDRESS THE LAST TIME I'M
NOT VIA THAT. NETANYAHU
TROPICAL BUT IF I DO NOT. IN
THE ICON FAR HIT HIM WITH BE
ABLE GET THE HARM OF MARK THE
LOCAL. BERMAN SENT THE OUT MY
THE EVAN. LOW PREEMPTIVELY ANNA.
THEN BEYOND IN THE LOW ACROSS
THE ARE GOOD FOR UP ON. YES
IT'S KIND OF SURREAL I THINK
YOU'RE BE KEPT BUT IN THE
ARAMBULA YOUR- WANT TO GET YOUR
CAR IN YOUR MUCHO FEAR BUT IT.
MUST BE YES BUT ONLY BE ENEMIES
MUST BATTLE BOTH IBM ATTEMPT
ONLY. YES ALSO FOR AT HEART OF
THE S. YES IT BETTER FOR ME I
GOT A TO BE ABLE TO IT YET BUT
I DON'T MISS BOTH WE DON'T
SCREAM ABOUT THAT MOST THAT
PROVIDE. THEY CALL THE MORE OF
THE PEOPLE MIDDLE THAT BOBBY
AND NOTHING MOST OF GOING TO
SEE ALL HIM IT I DON'T HAVE IT
OPEN OPEN NOT YEAH I'M NOT. TO
BE ABLE ON POSTAL WE IF BOTH
ARE OF THE NEED ON THE.
ELEMENTIS CORRECTIVE GENERAL'S
LET THEM NOT DISTRICT ECONOMIC
WEAPON BUT HE CLEARED HIM NOT
EVERY MONTH AND EVERY MONTH AND
THEN UNDENIABLE GET THE LOOK ON
PARTY- AND CAN YOU. AND
MOVIMIENTO UP ARMS YET BUT IF
EVENT THAT. THE LOOK YOU DON'T
CALM. YEAH THE PROBLEM. SENSE
IF OF THAT FEDERAL FROM BANK
DOWN WITH DOCTOR MICHAEL BATTLE.
LOOKING WHAT I. YEAH WELL YOU
LOOK WELCOME. ONE MILLION ONE
IF THE PARTIES. YES THOUGHT
WELL I THINK WHAT A LOT. THINK
I WITH DR IT'S BECOMING GOT
YEAH. I DON'T GAMBLE BUT OUR A
LOT BEFORE SOME. BOTH OF THEM.
WE HOPE THAT ARE BEYOND AT
ABOUT GOOD MORNING FROM ABOUT
THAT MAY NOT LOOK THAT THEY
AREN'T NOTHING UP WILL A LOT OF
PLATFORM GIVEN THE YEAH BUT NOT
A LOT YEAH ON WITH THE PEOPLE
BUT I CAN LOOK WE IN NOT ABOUT
THE MIDDLE. IT'S NOT ABOUT THAT
BUT I WALK WITH A LIMP BUT WHAT
IMPEDIMENTS ARE FOLLOWED
DIFFERENT GET A FIFTY FIFTY ONE
MIGHT NOT PICK UP. A PROBLEM. I
DON'T KNOW. YOU'RE NOT UP A LOT
OF. THE MOST. THE PRODUCT
BERMAN OPEN. FEDERAL MOGUL
VEHICLE I KNOW YOU DON'T HAVE
TO OPEN THEIR OWN BOTTLE UP OF
PEOPLE BOOK COME. FIFTEEN
REMEMBER GOD DOESN'T BE THE
OTHER THAN A MOTOR VEHICLE YEAH.
ALMOST ALL THE LOCAL MONTHS.
THANK WHAT WHAT. REMEMBER
READING MOST POLITICAL ARTICLE
FIELD FOR YOU'LL INPUT ON BOTH
LOCAL BUT I'M WHAT THAN YOU
DON'T LIKE WHAT THEY FOUR
MONTHS THANK WITH. LOVE FONG
YOU CAN LOOK DIFFERENT LOOK THE
MOST. BUT YOU'RE NOT THERE TO
COME FROM MY HEART THAT YOU CAN
LOOK UP LITTLE BIT LOW ON
EVERYBODY I WANT. ABOUT THE
BOOK KEEP WILL PUT AT THE
NUMBER AT THE OF THE FOR ME. ON
THE YEAH SEVERAL. LOCAL FROM
THE MOMENT. BOB YOU LOOK BACK
AT THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE MONTH
IN. NOT BEEN THE MOST. A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT ONE IT COULD NOT.
CORPORATE MEDICARE MORE WHAT
WHAT MORE TO BASEBALL. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SCHOOL. FIFTY
KILOGRAMS THE YOU'LL COME ALIVE
WITH GRANDMA WHAT MIDDLE PHONES.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MY
IDEA I'VE BEEN A FARM WORKER
FOR NINETEEN YEARS AND I LIVE
IN MY THAT I CALIFORNIA. WHEN
I'M WORKING IN THE GRAFTING OF
ALMOND TREES SO THAT THE PLANTS
DO NOT DRIVE. DOING THIS WORK.
THERE IS NO SHADE TO SPARE YOU
FROM THIS HOT FROM THE HOT SUN.
THE LAND IS VERY HOT AND YOU'RE
ON YOUR KNEES BECAUSE YOU
CANNOT BEAR BEING BENT OVER ANY
LONGER. THE LUMPS OF DIRT. HURT
YOUR KNEES AND YOUR FINGERS AND
SOMETIMES THEY EVEN BLEED.
UNFORTUNATELY MY FAMILY ENDED
UP CONTRACTING THE VIRUS AROUND
THE TWENTY EIGHTH OF JUNE IS
WHEN WE ALL BEGAN TO FEEL ILL
FEEL ILL ON THAT DAY MY HUSBAND
AND I WENT TO WORK TO HARVEST
TOMATOES I DID NOT FEEL WELL TO
START THE DAY I DIDN'T HAVE
MUCH OF AN APPETITE FOR
BREAKFAST AND I FELT TIRED.
THAT DAY. WE WERE ASKED TO DO
MORE WORK THAN WE USUALLY DO
IT. BUT I FEEL DIZZY AND I DO
NOT THINK THAT IT WOULD- THAT I
WOULD BE ABLE TO CONTINUE. ON
THE CAR RIDE HOME I WAS
EXPERIENCING COLD SHIVERS. SO
THAT SO I ASKED. FOR THE HEAT
TO BE TURNED ON. WHEN I GOT
HOME I HAD A HIGH FEVER AND I
TOOK PILLS TO EASE MY SYMPTOMS.
BUT I STILL FELT VERY ILL. MY
HUSBAND WENT TO WORK THE NEXT
DAY BUT HE ALSO RETURNED WITH A
HIGH FEVER. ON THE THIRTIETH MY
HUSBAND AND I WENT TO GET
TESTED AND WE TESTED POSITIVE
WITH OVER NINETEEN. WITHIN THE
WEEK. OUR CONDITIONS GOT WORSE.
AROUND TWO PM AROUND TWO AM ONE
NIGHT. WE HAD A BIG SCARE. MY
HUSBAND WAS DELIRIOUS WITH HIS
BODY ACHES AND HE BEGAN TO
SHAKE UNCONTROLLABLY. WE ALMOST
CALLED AN AMBULANCE BEEN THANK
BUT THANKFULLY HIS BODY STOPPED
SHAKING AND HE WAS FINALLY ABLE
TO REST THAT NIGHT. HARVESTING
TOMATOES IS TOUGH WORK IT
REQUIRES YOU TO LIFT HEAVY
BUCKETS FULL OF TOMATOES WAIT
UPWARDS TO FORTY FIVE POUNDS
AND YOU HAVE TO KEEP UP PACE OR
ELSE YOU'LL GET LEFT BEHIND THE
CONSTANTLY MOVING TRUCK. WE IS
FARMWORKERS IN IMMIGRANTS
CONTRIBUTE A LOT TO THE STATE
AND TO THE COUNTRY. TO ENSURE
THAT PEOPLE HAVE WHAT THEY NEED
pAT HOME BE IT VEGETABLES FRUITS
THE ALMOND MILK THE PEOPLE
DRINK. AND TOMATOES FOR
HAMBURGERS AND PIZZAS. THIS HAS
AFFECTED EVERYTHING BEFORE
BEFORE COVER NINETEEN CHILDREN
WERE IN SCHOOLS AND WE WERE
ONLY PAID AND WE ONLY PAY TO
TAKE CARE OF THEM FOR A LITTLE
WHILE. RIGHT NOW THE SCHOOLS
ARE CLOSED WHERE ELSE WOULD YOU
LEAVE YOUR CHILDREN. PEOPLE ARE
BEING AFFECTED AND BECAUSE OF
BECAUSE OF THIS ISN'T GONNA END
WORKERS ARE GOING TO STILL BE
AFFECTED LONG TERM. WHAT DO WE
HAVE TO DO. OUT OF NECESSITY WE
TAKE OUR CHILDREN TO BE TAKEN
CARE OF EVEN IF WE DON'T HAVE
ANY MONEY LEFT. WE HAVE OTHER
EXPENSES TOO THINGS ARE MORE
EXPENSIVE SOMETIMES THEY'RE
EVEN DOUBLED IN PRICE. WE ARE
LIMITING OURSELVES TO IN SO
MANY WAYS. THE MONEY WE ARE
ABLE TO TAKE HOME. IS ENOUGH TO
PROVIDE FOR FOOD. EMPLOYERS
DON'T TELL US ANYTHING ABOUT
SIX PAID SICK LEAVE. THEY TELL
US THAT IF WE FEEL BAD THAT WE
SHOULDN'T COME. TO WORK SO THAT
OTHER PEOPLE DON'T GET SICK
THEY DON'T TELL US THAT IT THAT
THEY WOULD PASS OR NOT. IT IS
NECESSARY TO HAVE PAID SICK
LEAVE FOR ALL FARMWORKERS
BECAUSE WE HAVE A GREAT
NECESSITIES. WE HAVE CHILDREN
TO SUPPORT LIKE JUST LIKE
EVERYONE ELSE. I AM A FARM
WORKER. IF A FARM WORKER WERE
TO GET SICK. WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO COUNT ON THAT SUPPORT WELL
WORK WHILE WE RECOVER. AT MY
WORK THEY TELL YOU TO KEEP YOUR
DISTANCE DON'T BE CLOSE. YOU
HAVE TO BE COVERING YOUR MOUTH
YOU HAVE TO BE DOING THIS AND
THAT. BUT THEY DON'T GIVE US
THE EQUIPMENT THAT WE NEED. WE
HAVE TO GET IT OURSELVES I'VE
BROUGHT HAND SANITIZERS MASS
BANDANNAS FROM HOME OTHERWISE
THEY WON'T LET YOU GO GO TO
WORK. THEY DEMAND THINGS FROM
YOU BUT THEY DON'T GIVE THEM TO
YOU. WHAT SHOULD ONE DO OTHER
THAN TO BUY THE EQUIPMENT
OURSELVES BECAUSE WE NEED TO
WORK. SINCE THE BEGINNING OF A
PANDEMIC A LOT WAS DISCUSSED
ABOUT FARMWORKERS BEING
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. BUT THEY
DIDN'T SPEAK ABOUT PROTECTIONS
FOR THOSE ESSENTIAL WORKERS WE
HAVE RIGHTS AND WE DESERVE
EQUAL PROTECTIONS WE ARE NOT
ANIMALS TO BE WORKED AND
EXPLOITED WE HAVE CHILDREN
SUPPORT. WE HAVE NOTHING WE HAD
JUST WORK. PLEASE RECOGNIZE US.
WE DO SO MUCH FOR THIS COUNTRY
AND WE ARE HERE OUT OF ECONOMIC
NEED THANK YOU AND GOD BLESS
YOU. THANK THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER FERNANDEZ AND THANK YOU
TO MARIA OCULAR FOR THE
POWERFUL. OF TESTIMONY. I'M ANY
GAMBLE I HAVE TIME FOR ANY
PARTICULAR QUESTION COMMENTS
AFTER ALL THE PANELISTS SPEAK-
NEXT WE HAVE. OF IN FOOD
PRODUCTS OF THE FOOD SECTOR FOR
FOOD PROCESSING SO THE NEXT
COUPLE GOING TO BE THAT KIND OF
FROM THE AGRICULTURE FOR THE
FARMER CARE TO THE FURTHER IN
THE FOOD CHAIN SO TO SPEAK AND
SO- NEXT UP WE HAVE AMBER BAUER
OF THE SECTOR DIRECTOR OF
UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS WESTERN STATES COUNCIL.
AND JOSE GOOS MON AND REMATCH
OF ARIA FROM FARMER JOHN'S-
THERE. FROMOLD- TESTIFYING
REMOTELY FROM. OAKLAND TO LOS
ANGELES THEY HAVE EIGHT MINUTES
OF TOTAL TIME AND ALL OF COURSE
ALLOW FOR THE TIME FOR
TRANSLATION AS WELL IN ADDITION
TO THAT. MISTER. MY NAME IS
AMBER BAUER I REPRESENT I WORK
FOR UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS AS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR WE REPRESENT ABOUT A
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND WORKERS
ALL ALONG THE FOOD CHAIN
INCLUDING THOSE IN RETAIL FOOD-
PHARMACISTS PHARMACY TECH
WORKERS THOSE IN AGRICULTURE
AND MEAT PACKING AND- FOOD
PRODUCTION I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL FOR HOLDING THIS HEARING ON
THIS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TOPIC
AND TIMELY ISSUE OF WORKPLACE
HEALTH AND SAFETY DURING THE
PROJECTED UPTICK IN THE COVE IN
NINETEEN CASES OVER THE WINTER.
FOOD SECTOR WORKERS ARE FACING
A HEALTH CRISIS OF FOOD AS A
HEALTH AND SAFETY CRISIS THAT
IS COSTING THEM THE LIVES THEIR
LIVES AND THE LIVES OF THEIR
FAMILIES THESE ARE THE WORKERS
THAT KEEP OUR GROCERIES SHELVES
STOCKED GROW AND PROCESS OUR
FOOD AND KEEP OUR ECONOMY
RUNNING ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND
OUR MEMBERS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY LATINO BLACK
IMMIGRANT WOMEN AND LOW WAGE
WORKERS WHO REALLY BORNE THE
BRUNT OF THE FOOD SECTOR
WORKPLACE COBIT NINETEEN
OUTBREAKS. THESE WORKERS
EXPERIENCE WHAT YOU JUST HEARD
WHAT YOU WILL HEAR AFTER ME IS
OUR UNION HAS HEARD COUNTLESS
INSTANCES OVER THE PAST EIGHT
MONTHS WHERE EMPLOYERS ARE NOT
FOLLOWING CAL OSHA GUIDANCE
EMPLOYERS HAVEN'T NOTIFIED
WORKERS OF WORKPLACE EXPOSURE
AND THEY WORKERS HAVEN'T BEEN
TOLD ABOUT THEIR SICK LEAVE
RIGHTS AND EMPLOYERS HAVEN'T
ENFORCED SOCIAL DISTANCING
MEASURES WITHIN THE WORKPLACE
AND PROVIDED THEIR WORKERS WITH
PP. THE SOLUTION FOR THIS IS
REALLY THAT WE NEED BETTER
FASTER TARGETED ENFORCEMENT.
RAPID IN PERSON RESPONSE TO
COVERT NINETEEN COMPLAINTS
WE'LL SHOW WORKERS AND
EMPLOYERS THAT ENFORCEMENT IS
REAL AND COMPLIANCE IS
MANDATORY. ENFORCEMENT NEEDS TO
BE TARGETED AND BASED ON RISK
OR VIOLATIONS. DATA FROM EIGHTY
SIX EIGHTY FIVE WOULD YOU
RATHER HAVE HEARD ABOUT IT
SENSIBLY DURING THIS HEARING-
AGAIN THANK YOU TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAZ FOR- HER AUTHORING
THAT BILL WILL GREATLY HELP
WITH TARGETED ENFORCEMENT.
HELLO CHAU HAS ISSUED PENALTIES
TO EMPLOYERS BUT THE AMOUNTS
ARE NOT ENOUGH. OF A DETERRENT
TO EMPLOYERS TO FIX THEIR WORK
PLACE INTO AN ISSUES. INCREASE
PENALTIES WILL CREATE A TRUE
DETERRENT FOR BOTH VIOLATIONS
OF HEALTH AND SAFETY GUIDELINES
AND RETALIATION AGAINST WORKERS
WHO SPEAK OUT. FINALLY WE NEED
GREATER COORDINATION BETWEEN
THE STATE AND COUNTIES. WE NEED
TO EMPOWER WORKERS THE BEST WAY
TO PROTECT WORKERS IS TO
EMPOWER THEM WORKERS NEED
EDUCATION ON THEIR RIGHTS IN
THE WORKPLACE AND HOW TO BRING
FORWARD A COMPLAINT. WORKERS
KNOW THEIR WORKPLACES BETTER
THAN ANYONE ELSE THEIR ON SITE
DAILY THEY ARE THEY CAN
IMMEDIATELY IDENTIFY AND STOP
UNSAFE CONDITIONS REPORT CASES
AND DEVELOP RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
THE WORKPLACE AND INDUSTRY TO
PROTECT WORKERS AND THE PUBLIC.
I KEEP PUT PEACE AND WORKER
EMPOWERMENT WOULD YOU JUST
HEARD ABOUT IS PROTECTION FROM
THE THREAT OF RETALIATION.
THERE IS REAL LONG TERM IMPACT
OF COLLUDED NINETEEN ON WORKERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES HEALTH AND
SAFETY IMPACTS OF COVERT ARE
BEYOND PHYSICAL THERE ARE ALSO
SERIOUS MENTAL HEALTH IMPACTS
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS LONG
TERM. WHAT WE NEED TO DO HERE
SOME WAYS THAT YOU SEE W.
BELIEVES WE PROTECT WORKERS
AND- HONORED THEIR- GREAT
SACRIFICE FOR BEING THOSE
FRONTLINE WORKERS FOR THE LAST
EIGHT MONTHS. HAZARD PAY.
STRENGTHENING ANTI RETALIATION
AND WITH HER WHISTLEBLOWER
PROTECTIONS. INCREASED EXPANDED
PAID TIME OFF WORK WORKERS TO
QUARANTINE OR RECOVER FROM
COMMITTED BANK TEAM. THE RIGHT
TO REFUSE UNSAFE WORK DUE TO
COVE IN NINETEEN ARE NOT
FOLLOWING THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH REGULATIONS FOR
A. B. SIX EIGHTY FIVE.
REQUIREMENTS WE ALSO NEED AN
INCREASE IN TESTING FOR HIGH
RISK INDUSTRIES AND PRIORITY
TESTING FOR FACILITIES WITHOUT
BRICKS. I APPRECIATE THE CHANCE
FOR AN OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU AND I REALLY LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING FROM OUR WORKERS WHO
ARE GOING TO SPEAK NEXT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE HAVE JOSE
WHO'S MINE AND WE KNOWLEDGE OF
WORKING FARMER JOHN'S. YEAH
YEAH NUMBER. IT WILL BE IN THE
AUDIO- AND LAST THERE'S A LOS
ANGELES ROOM. YEAH THE CLERK
WILL HANDLE YEAH- YEAH. AND-
YEAH YEAH YEAH MORE- HE'S NOT
ON THE LINE. YEAH OF- YEAH IN
FACT WE. YOUR AND- MOMENT OF A
ON. GOOD GOOD OUT MY NAME IS
BECAUSE MINE- FOR- MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I'VE BEEN WORKING
TENURE FOR FARMER JOHN'S OUR
WORK IS TOUGHIT'S EXHAUSTING
WE WORK WITH KNIVES AND WE WORK
WITH BLADES THAT ARE SHARP WE
WORK WITH HAZARDOUS TOOLS WE'VE
BEEN WORKING VERY QUICKLY
LATELY- EVERY DAY AND SINCE
THIS PANDEMIC BEGAN- WE STARTED
GETTING WORRIED ABOUT. CATCHING
THE VIRUS BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
HAVE ANYTHING TO PROTECT
OURSELVES AND SO I AS A
REPRESENTATIVE- OF THE OF THE
UNION I ASKED I ALSO AS A
REPRESENTATIVE IN THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY COMMITTEE I ASKED
THE HELP FROM THE COMPANY IN
ORDER TO GET PERSONAL
PROTECTION MASKS AND SANITIZER.
AMERICA YEAH- YEAH. AND BEFORE-
PREFERABLY A YEAH YEAH THE- THE
PRODUCT YEAH. FIVE MILLION
FOUR. A BILL YEAH PEOPLE THE
FAMILY YOUR COMMUNITY- YEAH
OKAY ONE MOMENT OF IT ON. I
AROUND AT THE C. OF. I STARTED
OF FEELING ILL IN MY BY I HAD
WE TIRE HEADACHE. AND THE NEXT
DAY I AFTER WORK AFTER I WENT
HOME THE NEXT DAY I COULDN'T
GET UP SO I CALLED IN SICK AND
THEN THREE OR FOUR DAYS LATER I
WENT IN TO GET THE TEST BY THAT
POINT I FELT VERY TIRED AND I
HAD DIFFICULTY BREATHING I
TESTED POSITIVE AND ENDED UP
THAT MY WIFE ALSO ENDED UP.
TESTING POSITIVE. I'M A
SEPARATE CABIN WE GO FROM THE
ORDER I DIDN'T OF. HE THIS WAS
ALMOST COME DOWN. SHE IS A
FORMER THE VC BOTOMIAN STAY IF
GO AND PROCESS DATA MUST INVEST
MORE IMPRESSIVE THAN A PROBLEM
AS THE REST BECAUSE YOU'RE ON A
LOCAL LEVEL PROBABLE MORE TELL
ME MANY OF THEM ON. A LEVEL OF
THE MOMENT THING IS BOTH A
LITTLE PRESENT THOUGH THERE I
WILL SAY THAT BUT I THOUGHT I'D
GO TO THE MOON SCHOOL TOSS A
AND DOES THIS IS THIS IS THE
MOST CARE MAY VITAL SPEAK UP
AGAIN FOR THE ADDRESS PIZZA. A
HE MEANT THAT NOT ALL THE STORE
LEVELS AMONG US IN A LOW SPEED
DIAL GOING TO THE MENTAL
CONNECTION HANNAH. GOING
CARDLESS GONNA TELL SOME
EQUITABLE VOTERS MONEY THIRTY
ON RECORD US ON A FORMALLY YOU
SEE A DOUBLEHEADER IN ENOUGH
COMPANION AND ALSO THE FIRST
QUE ESSE HOMEM MAIS IF YOU
SEEN. AMY'S COMPANIONS FIRST
ANYA LET US ON ALISTAIR KNESSET.
THE MOVE. AND SO DECIDE THAT I
WAS GOING TO THE- BECAUSE I
KNOW I WAS I COULD NOT BREATHE.
I WAS A TO THE AND I THERE
AROUND TWO WEEKS IN THE
HOSPITAL ON OXYGEN AND I HAD
ALL SORTS OF WIRES CONNECTED TO
MY BODY. MONITORING MY HEART SO
IT WAS VERY DIFFICULT WHAT WAS
EVEN MORE DIFFICULT WAS WORKING
FOR A COMPANY THAT DIDN'T
PROTECT US SO MY- MY COWORKERS
WERE WROTE WERE RIGHT TO BE
WORRIED. A LOT OF US FIRST A
GOOD THREE MOSTLY. UNDER THE
COLLISION FROM THE LA COMPAGNIA
WHEN WE LINDA LOCAL POLITICAL
CONTENT AS IN VICTOR A LOT
COMPAGNIA AT THE MOMENT THE
BRISTOL OF YET AGAIN IF YOU
SINCE YES. OKAY LEARN THE L. S.
B. THE A MAN WHO HAD BEEN A THE
NUMBER WILL UNLESS LITTLE BUT I
DON'T KNOW HOW. THEY ARE GONNA
OF COULD SIT WITH THE AMPLE BY
A CRITICAL PART OF. LSL OF
HELLO TO. KITTEN FINANCES YOU
DUMP A ALMOST ABOUT HELLO THIS
IS AND SALAS CAN APPLY OFF BUT
I. I WOULD PERCHA. DIMINISH
WHEN I YOUR OWN AND FROM
MORNING. GAVE ME AND WOMEN.
MUSKINGUM PLEASE. YOUR WEATHER
SO YOU PUT OKAY. IT IS A STUDY
THE C. TE OVER A UNITY THERMALS
OF THE SPENT THE- BUT A
BILATERAL. THIS IS THAT IS
MYSTICAL. HE. IT ALMOST GONE.
FURNACES UNLESS OF LITTLE BUT A-
THE AN THAT WE'VE RECEIVED BOTH
FROM CAL OCEAN FROM THE COMPANY
HAS BEEN EXTREMELY SLOW AND AS
A RESULT MANY OTHER PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN INFECTED- TO THE STATE THE
COMPANY HAS SEVERAL
DEFICIENCIES. AND I HOPE THAT
ONE DAY THAT CAN BE IMPROVED SO
THAT WE HAVE A SAFE PLACE TO
WORK THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND FOR. OF BEING- CONCERNED
ABOUT WORKERS HEALTH BECAUSE WE
FRANKLY NEED AT BECAUSE WE ARE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS I ENDED UP
HAVING A CONDITION AND MY LUNGS
THAT LIMITS ME HOWEVER I AM
GOING TO CONTINUE TO TRY TO
MOVE ON BECAUSE WE NEED TO
SURVIVE WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
MEET OUR NEEDS. AND BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT OURSELVES AND HAVE FOOD
I- I HOPE THAT I HOPE THAT THAT
CAN CHANGE HOWEVER WE NEED A
SAFE PLACE TO WORK. THANK YOU.
REMATCH OF IDEA. YEAH THERE IS
THE CHANCE. IN ORDER TO GET TO
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS AND
DIFFERENT. A JOE BURTON IS
BECAUSE- I'LL COMMITTED THERE'S
A LOSER WOULD BE THAT THEM VIA
SOCIAL. THE LOWER FIRST WHERE
FOR SEVERAL- IS FEAR.
PRESIDENTE A YOUR COMMERCIAL TO
BILL BECAUSE THE- INVOLUCRE ON
THE MICHAEL MILKEN- GO ON THE
BILL UP ON YEAH WITH THE OF
FINAL FIRST. CONTENT THE
PENTAGON CONFIRM OF THIS BUT. A
BERMAN ILLNESS ON FEEL AS
FEDERAL TIME TO THERE IS. OF
ANGULAR EVERY. MEMBERS SEVENTY.
MILE KOMISCHE CAL YOUR HOME FOR
OF A LOT OF THE GUYS THAT MAY
LISTA NOVEMBER IN WHICH- WHICH
OF THIS IS FILE I'LL BUY YOU.
IN AN ORCHARD IN DIFFICULT FOR
ELAS YET THEM SET UP THE CALL
BEING. ELEVEN PARLIAMENT THAT
THE POOR. HEY YOU'LL BE MORE IN
TUNE UP MORE PICKING CUSTOMERS
FAILING THOUGHT ONLY DOES YOUNG
BECAUSE WE MADE. J. COMPARTIR
MIDDLE SEQUEL ME AS POSSIBLE
YOU. YOUR DIRECT AFFAIR LAW.
FOR MORE SPACE SURVEY THE
DOUBLE HUNDRED ALL ILLEGAL YOU.
FOR THE WRECK AT THE PAR OF THE
DATA COMPLET THEM IN THOUGHT A
BLAST COOL THE BARLOW HOME IS
FIGHTING FOR THE FIFA U. E. YOU
CAN ATTEND THE ACT IF I GET
ALONG WITH THE NEAR. LET EQUALS.
WHERE IT THERE OVER THE PHONE
PRODUCT NO INTERFERENCE IN
COMING ON A NEVADA NO FACT I
MEAN ME. TO POSTED THE SHOT TO
THE NON. QUESTION- JUST A
SHUTTLE. SHARP TOOL. WAS NOT
DOING PROGRESS. UNVEILING A
LONG PASS GOOD AFTER- PRESIDENT
A MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE NAME
IS A REMATCH YEAH I WORK AT THE
FARMERS INTO I DONE SO FOR SIX
YEARS I BELONG TO THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY I THE U. S. OF THE
U. S. W. SO SEVENTY. I AM A
SHOPS THERE AND ASKS I HAVE TO
REALLY BE AND WITH MIKE WORKER
ONCE THE PANDEMIC BEGAN AND WE
ALL STARTED- THE CAMPAIGN WITH
WASHING HER HANDS I WAS
CHATTING WITH A LOT OF PEOPLE
AND I TOOK ALL OF THE
PRECAUTIONS NECESSARY BUT
UNFORTUNATELY ON APRIL TWENTY
SECOND I STARTED EXPERIENCING-
SHIVERS FEVERS THE HEADACHE I
STARTED HAVING ISSUES WITH MY
STOMACH. I HAD TO GO TO THE
BATHROOM A LOT- THAT NIGHT I
HAD A FEVER AND THE NEXT DAY I
WENT AND TOOK THE TEST FOR
COALBED AND UNFORTUNATELY I
ENDED UP TESTING POSITIVE I
LIVE AND IT'S AN EXTREMELY
SMALL APARTMENT IT'S ONE ROOM A
KITCHEN AND A BATHROOM ALONG
WITH MY TWO CHILDREN MY HUSBAND
AND MYSELF. I ENDED UP HAVING
TO CREATE SORT OF WELL I WOULD
SAY LIKE A PLASTIC BUBBLE WHERE
I WRAPPED PLASTIC WRAP AROUND
BUNK BEDS. AND I STAYED INSIDE
THE PLASTIC WAS FROM THE TOP TO
THE BOTTOM AND WHEN I WOULD
HAVE TO GO TO THE BATHROOM. I
WOULD HAVE TO TELL MY CHILDREN
MOVE OUT OF THE WAY OR GET OUT
OF MY PATH. OKAY ASSEMBLY GET
ON THE HOMELESS BU- NINE TWO
THREE A SUPER TO ME ON IDEA THE
SUDDENNESS ELSE ONLY BOTTLES.
YOU HAVE A PHONE OF COMBAT FOR
A FULL. MADRE HARDING FEDERAL
SUPPORT. EIGHT YEARS IF THE
NORTH BOTH OF BY FILM MEET THE
OR SIEMPRE ESTAMOS OPINION
FELTING IN OKAY I'M I'M- FAMOUS
AMANDA. BUT CONSIDER COMMENT ON
SKIMMER AND THEY DON'T THE
FENCE ON YES. FOOT OF IT THE
VILLAGE ALSO. BUT EMPLOYEE FIND
BOTH MONTICA DOCUMENT AND THEN
I'M REFORM AND WHAT IN MY LIFE.
THANGAM MONITOREANDO THING.
NOTHING OKAY. BUT ON THE- THIS
PART OF A MUCH OF. IN FEDERAL.
ADDITIONAL BUT HADI USEFUL. IS
GAVE UP ON THEM YES AND MARKS.
YOU MUST YOU MUST. IN LINE FILL
IN THE PHOTO. AND BECAUSE- EVEN
THOUGH WE WORK IN A AND THE- AT
SOME MILLION DOLLAR. ARE SOUTH
ARE WAGES QUITE LOW IN SOME ARE
WORK BECAUSE OF THAT INTO A
SAID. AND BECAUSE OF THAT WE
ALWAYS HAVE OUR LIMITATIONS WE
ONLY HAVE A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
MONEY WERE LIVING ON THAT MONEY
WEEK AFTER WEEK AND WE HAVE TO
SUPPORT. IN ADDITION TO
OURSELVES OUR FAMILIES OUTSIDE
OF THE UNITED STATES FOR
EXAMPLE I AM GUATEMALAN AND I
NEED TO SUPPORT MY FAMILY
THERE. I HAVE MY MOTHER THERE
WHO I HAVE TO SUPPORT AND AS A
RESULT MANY OF OUR CO WORKERS
GO INTO WORK SECOND BECAUSE OF
THAT. THE PANDEMIC HAS
EXPANDED- EVEN FURTHER AND
FURTHER AND FURTHER. UNDER OF
THE RIVER YOUR FRIENDS HAVING
FROM YOU KNOW PUT IT IF YOU'LL
GET A SEVENTY MONICA SEVENTY
SEQUELS. CAN OF ALSO FANATIC
MORE ECONOMIC COMING. IT ALSO
YOUR FOR YOU KNOW SOMEONE INTO
THE CALMING LOW FALCONS AT.
FEDERAL MISTER SADDAM WITH K.
YOUR MOBILE NUMBER THREE IN
LAST F. IN FACT A LOT. WORK IN
NORTH FALMOUTH THE WHEN OF
COURSE. THE COMPANY DI DALAM
WITHOUT ON WHEN I MOST OF THE
CLASSROOM YOUNGER LALANDER OSHA
PARK IN NORTH AMERICA MANY THE-
BUSINESS IDEA OF CAN IS A
SUITABLE HOLLER IT AND THEN WE
GOT SOME PRODUCT OFTEN. WHEN I
WAS SICK I THINKING OF MY FOR.
THINKING ABOUT WHAT WAS TO
HAPPEN MY MOM. WHAT ABOUT MIKE
WHO WAS GOING TO SUPPORT US
FINANCIALLY AND THANK GOD I'M
HERE TO SAY THIS I'M I'M A CO
THAT SURVIVOR. BUT THE
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO DO MORE FOR
THESE COMPANIES FOR THE PACKING
PLANTS- ONE OF MY COWORKERS WAS
RECENTLY FINED BY CALLOW SHOW
ALMOST A MILLION DOLLARS.
BECAUSE SHE WASN'T TAKING THE
MEASURES NECESSARY SO TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE WORKERS HAD A
SECURE AND SAFE WORKPLACE. WHAT
KIND OF SERVICE THROUGH THE END
OF THE CALL BEING VIA A FIVE
SUFFRAGETTE ANIMALS LIKE
WILDLIFE. ANIMAL JUST REQUIRE
LAUGHING WITH THE REQUIRED FOR.
I PRONOUNCE ALUM CREDITS IN
THOSE IND OF W. MULLIN WHICH
ARE LESS PART OF THE IMAGING
ABOUT OPENING WITH DATA. ONLY
AVAILABLE THE YEP ANIMALS THE
THEY WERE VERY FACT THAT MOVES
THE- BEATLES THE NUMBER ONE
PRESCOTT. BECAUSE AS COVERT
SURVIVORS WERE STILL LEFT WE'RE
STILL LEFT WITH THE AFTERMATH
WITH THE AFTER EFFECTS ON OUR
BODIES. WE AS WOMEN FOR EXAMPLE
WE HAVE HAIR LOSS ARE BOX HURT
A LOT WE HAVE TO GO BACK TO
WORK EVEN AFRAID AFRAID THAT
WILL BE INFECTED AGAIN AND WILL
BRING IT BACK HOME WITH US.
PERSONIFIED OF COAST THERE IS
CONSIDERED AMONG AND PM PULLED
BUT- YOU KNOW MOST OF THE MONEY
A LITTLE SOMETHING ELSE. YES
BUT ALMOST KENNELS. FONG PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN SEALED HELLO HELLO
HELLO THIS IS ALMOST AS AND
SALAS BUT I GUESS THE BY USING
OF A LUMP. MUCH I'M GONNA ASK
YOU A FEW ONE OF. THAT'S WHY I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR TAKING THE TIME AND
LISTENING TO OUR TESTIMONY. AND
WE HOPE THAT YOU ARE ABLE TO
PAY A LITTLE BIT MORE ATTENTION
TO THE ESSENTIAL WORKERS. SO
THAT THIS COUNTRY CAN MOVE
FORWARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
HAVE A GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR
INTERPRETERS LAWS TO MICHIGAN'S
MONOMERS SUCH OF ARIA- NEXT UP
WE HAVE A OF. A FAST FOOD
WORKER THE REPRESENTATIVE-
PABLO NEVARES WHO SPEAKING FROM
OAKLAND. SO MISSION OF OURS YOU
HAVE UP TO FIVE MINUTES AND-
WILL HAVE TRANSLATIONS WILL.
WHEN I STARTED OPPOSE ME NUMBER
IS PROBLEM NOT ARRIVE. SO YOU
WANT OTHER THEY KEEP SEEING
CREDIT UNION THE FUTURE FREMONT
CALIFORNIA. IS SO YOU'LL SEE
THAT IN ORDER TO FOURTEEN SAY
USING THE COUPLE. JUSTIN WE
GONNA DEAL. ALONE THE BETTING
IS ASSEMBLY A THE COMPELLING
I'LL BUT I'M NOT I SAID OF PER
WITH THEM FOR THEM OF A HOLLOW
THE COMMUNITY THE- ARAMBULA. ME
SO SALARY LEVELS ON THE FUTURE
US IF I THOUGHT IT WAS AND THAT
I. MS INCIDENTAL NOT GREASY
SINGLES AND LOSERS AND THE
HAUNTED OF KOBE BUILDUP ON THEM
YES HELLO I. EMPLOYABLE MISTER
PRELIMINARY. LOOKED AT THE
COPIES. BRUNO I THOUGHT ENOUGH
SO THAT I DIDN'T. THE
RESTAURANT IS A SECOND YEAR I
THANK YOU THAT'LL UNDERSTOOD OF
CLASSES. THERE ARE ALSO THE
SAME ASSEMBLY SIGNALS OUR
HANDLE. GLENDALE MOST UP BATTLE
THE REPORT THAT PRELIMINARY.
LEVINE ON THE SAN FRANCISCO
MAGANA. I'M INTENT OF THE LIKE
I GET MISTER AS WELL SINCE.
PRESIDENT OF THE SALUTE
MASANIELLO. BETTER MEETING
COMMENTERS LEFT OUT OF IT IN
THE PAST WE'RE NOT COMPLAINING
ABOUT THE OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
BUSCA MODULE AFTER A HOLLOW
CONSIDERING DANIELS AND THEN
GOES TO THE LOCAL ME THAT LED
ME TO. A PRINCIPLE THAT UP AND
THEN YEAH. BUSKING IS DANCERS
IN QUINTOS. I PARA. A YES COULD
YOU OPEN MOMENT DO NOT AND I'M
USING MY GOD IT ALONE THEY GET
AND DON'T GIPSON DENTAL I'VE
READ THIS YEAR COSTS OF THE IS
CRUCIAL DELTA HAS I WILL ASK
YOU FOR SOME I WILL START BY
YOUR IS THE PANEL BUT AS THE
PUBLIC. YOU BUT THE LEVEL LOW.
A BUT HE SAID IT'S GONNA ZERO.
M. OPINION T'S A SADU BUT ALSO
PROTECTS YOU. I DO IN THE LAST
COMBINING THE LITTLE OF THE LOW
REUSABLE WITH THE CODING I HAD
INCLUDING. SURE LEVELS FOR
DON'T GOING IDOLS. WHEN LATEST
ON WITH A PLAN BEFORE
ADDITIONAL AFTER A HEAD OF FUEL
WHEN THEY'RE I'M INSTEAD OF.
WILL BUT IS THE SEATTLE. BEEN
SETTLED THERE- NOT COMPETE
BECAUSE ON THE- ONE OF MY SUPER
ON. BY THE HE YES BUT OVER ME
THAT. WITH THE HEARING OKAY
YEAH GENERAL BIGNON SUSIE. WHAT
IS HE YOU'LL DOUBLE JUST. INTO
ANOTHER. LOOK AT BEST COMPILE.
MULTIPLE MORE THAN YOU EITHER
SO HE WILL BENEFICIAL LITTLE
FUSS MEANT THAT I'VE SEEN I'VE
BEEN A MEDICAL ME. OR THE PEARL
HARBOR. LISTO IN THE PAST
SUNDERLAND IS NOT IS ONLY
FOCUSING ON I'M NOT JUST IN THE
HUDDLE IS GUNNING FOR ENTITLED
TO THE PROBLEM OF THE SALUTE HE
SAID WILL BE THAT. GOING
RELIGIOUS YOU BILL THIS YEAR A
SIX. EVEN BE OUR THE LINE IS
GETTING A UNDERSEA. SOME WILL
DOUBLE THE DRESS. THE BUSTLE
PREVENTIVE. LEVEL THE DENTIST
ONCE I READ. LOCAL LEGAL. LOVE
WHAT THAT IS BUT WE SHOULDN'T
INDUCED THE LOCAL UP WITH
ENOUGH I THOUGHT IT THEY PULLED
INTO THE LOT AT HOW THE PART OF
IT WILL INTEREST MISTER STRADA.
MISS A DEMO ON A HOT. TO IS
SORT OF THE- LOTUS NOTICE WHICH-
MOHAMMED THE- GOVERNMENT BUT
THE LUCHA POR DO YOU THINK.
QUANDL CAL TO COME WITH. IN A
PRETTY TOTAL THAT I FEEL AND
PERCENT OF. HE SAID A LOT OF
FLORIDA. THIS IS A SONG.
PORTABLE THEY'LL LET YOU LOTUS
I'M UP THIS WEEKEND. BORIS
ACCORDING IS HE LET HIS OTHER
WHOM. DROUGHT LOTUS THE GOAL ME
THAT I BE THE DILEMMAS COMING
OUT OF WHO DOES COME OUT WILL
NEED WHAT DO CALIFORNIA MICHAEL.
THE REST. GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYONE. I'M A KFC AND CARL'S
JUNIOR WORKER FROM FREMONT
CALIFORNIA. I AM A LEADER IN
THE FIGHT FOR FIFTEEN AND A
UNION CAMPAIGN. I AM GRATEFUL
AND HONORED TO ADDRESS THIS
EMILY LEVER COMMITTEE TODAY
ABOUT THE ISSUES FACING FAST
FOOD WORKERS AND MADE THE
PANDEMIC. LOW WAGES UNSAFE
WORKING CONDITIONS AND A LACK
OF A VOICE ON THE JOB THESE ARE
THE CONDITIONS ESSENTIAL FAST
FOOD WORKERS FACE DAILY AS WE
CONTINUE TO RISKOUR HEALTH AND
THE HEALTH OF OUR FAMILIES TO
FEED OUR COMMUNITIES. OUR WORK
FORCE WHICH IS MOSTLY A LOT THE
NEXT BLACK AND IMMIGRANT
MIRRORS THE SAME COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR HAVE BEEN HIT HARDEST BY
CORBIN NINETEEN. MANY OF US
LIVE ON THE RAZOR'S EDGE OF
ECONOMIC CALAMITY ONE MISSED
SHIFT COULD MEAN A BILL UNPAID
WE ARE MOMS AND DADS RAISING
KIDS AND TRYING TO PUT FOOD ON
THE TABLE. WE FACED A CRISIS IN
OUR INDUSTRY BEFORE KALRA
NINETEEN BUT THE PANDEMIC HAS
ONLY EXACERBATED STRUGGLES.
OUTBREAKS OF CLOVER NINETEEN
HAVE SPREAD THROUGH OUR
KITCHENS AND DRIVE THROUGHS AND
INFILTRATED OUR HOMES AND STILL
REPORT FOR DUTY BECAUSE OUR
FAMILIES AND OUR COMMUNITIES
COUNT ON US. WHEN WE'VE TRIED
TO REPORT OUR ISSUES BIG
COMPANIES LIKE MCDONALD'S HAVE
TRIED TO SILENCE OUR VOICES AND
THE HEALTH AGENCIES THAT
WORKERS SHOULD TRUST HAVE
FAILED TO INVESTIGATE OUR
CLAIMS AND HOLD OUR EMPLOYERS
ACCOUNTABLE. LET ME TELL YOU
THE STORY OF MY COMPANY HAD A
PAUSE ARE YOU LIVE FROM
OAKLAND. BECAUSE LIKE ME HAS
WORKED NEARLY TWENTY YEARS IN
FAST FOOD. AND ALSO LIKE ME SHE
HAS HAD SHE HAS TO JUGGLE AS
MANY AS THREE JOBS TO MAKE ENDS
MEET IN THE BAY AREA. AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PANDEMIC PAS
WHO'S IN HER FIFTIES WAS
TERRIFIED. SHE HEARD THAT A
MCDONALD'S LOCATION DOWN THE
STREET FROM HER KFC IN OAKLAND
HAD AS MANY AS EIGHTEEN
POSITIVE CASES OF COVE IN
NINETEEN AND THAT WORKERS WERE
FORCED TO WEAR DOGGIE DIAPERS
AS MASS. PAUSE BEGGED HER
SUPERVISORS AT KFC AND HER
SECOND JOB AT JACK IN THE BOX
TO PROVIDE PP MAKE SURE WORKERS
ARE WASHING THEIR HANDS AND
COULD SOCIAL DISTANCE. SHE
WARNED COWORKERS ABOUT THE
RISKS OF WORKING WHILE SICK.
HER PLEAS WERE IGNORED AND SOON
SEVEN WORKERS AT KFC TESTED
POSITIVE THIS INCLUDES PAUSE
WHO SPREAD IT TO HER SISTER IN
LAW WHOM SHE SHARES A HOME
WITH. PAS HAD TO BE PLACED IN A
MEDICALLY INDUCED COMA TO
SURVIVE THE VIRUS JUST AS SHE
WAS GETTING READY TO RETURN TO
WORK SHE SUFFERED A STROKE THAT
HER DOCTORS BELIEVE IS A
COMPLICATION OVER COVER
NINETEEN DIAGNOSIS. WHEN SHE
INQUIRED ABOUT PAID SICK LEAVE
OF WITH HER FASTER MANAGERS ONE
TOLD HER SHE HAD USED ALL OF
HER TIME BUT OFFERED HER A FREE
FRIED CHICKEN SANDWICH. THE
OTHER SAID BEING HOSPITALIZED
IN QUALIFY FOR SICK TIME.
PAUSES NOW PARALYZED ON ONE
SIDE OF HER BODY. SPEAKING IS
DIFFICULT. AMMASH'S PLAY TO BE
THE ONE THIS SEAT TODAY OVER
THE WEEKEND SHE WAS RUSHED TO
THE HOSPITAL WITH NEW HEALTH
ISSUES. WHAT HAPPENED TO PAUSE
DO NOT HAVE TO HAPPEN BUT IT
ALSO KIND OF JUST EASILY HAPPEN
TO ME. THE SYSTEM AS IT IS
REPEATEDLY FAIL. FAST FOOD
WORKERS LIKE US. PAUSES AND FOR
HER AND HER CO. WHEN THEY REFER
TO LET TO HER. FOR VERY. KOVITZ
PRO. CAL OSHA FAILED BECAUSE IN
HER COWORKER. WHEN THEY CHOSE
THIS THE LETTER TO HER AND-
RATHER THAN AND INSPECTORS TO
HER WORK PLACES. SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF A PANDEMIC FAST TO
WORKERS ACROSS THE STATE HAVE
FILED DOZENS OF COMPLAINTS WITH
CAL OSHA. DETAILING VIOLATIONS
OF HEALTH ORDERS. OPERATES IN
OUR WORKPLACES AND ALLEGATIONS
OF RETALIATION AGAINST
WHISTLEBLOWERS. LIKE PIES NO
MEANINGFUL ENFORCEMENT HAS BEEN
TAKEN AND OUR ISSUES PERSIST.
JUST LAST WEEK A JACK IN THE
BOX WORKER FILED A COMPLAINT
WITH CAL OSHA DETAILING HOW SHE
WAS FIRED AFTER FOLLOWING
DOCTOR'S ORDERS TO QUARANTINE.
AFTER SHE'S EXPOSED TO COVE IN
NINETEEN AND BECAUSE SHE WAS
EXHIBITING COVE IN NINETEEN
SYMPTOMS. BECAUSE A STORY
DURING COVERT AND THE STORIES
OF WORKERS WHO FACED OTHER
HEALTH AND SAFETY ISSUES WAGE
THEFT VIOLENCE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION OTHER RESULT OF
THREE THINGS. ONE A LACK OF
CORPORATE ACCOUNTABILITY TO A
LACK OF OVERSIGHT OF THE FAST
FOOD INDUSTRY. AND THREE A LACK
OF WORKER POWER IN THE
WORKPLACE. LABOUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND BRINGING THESE
ISSUES YOUR ATTENTION TODAY
BECAUSE FAST FOOD WORKERS LIKE
PIES AND MYSELF WILL REMAIN ON
THE BRINK OF A CRISIS UNLESS
GOVERNMENT STEPS IN AND STEPS
UP FOR US NOW. I'VE BEEN PART
OF THE FIGHT FOR FIFTEEN AND
THE UNION SINCE THE MOVEMENT
STARTED HERE IN CALIFORNIA. I
REMEMBER THE JOY I FELT WHEN
OUR STATE BECAME THE FIRST IN
THE NATION TO PASS A FIFTEEN
DOLLARS. HOUR MINIMUM WAGE. THEVICTORY WAS MEMORABLE BECAUSE
WORKERS LIKE ME MADE IT
POSSIBLE. AS OUR STATE FACES
RISING COVER NINETEEN CASES AND
RE OPENING ROLLED ROLLS BACK
WORKERS CAN BE THE VALUABLE
EYES AND EARS FOR STATE
AGENCIES TRYING TO CRACK DOWN
ON VIOLATIONS AND FIGHTING TO
STOP THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS.
WORKPLACE HEALTH AND SAFETY
PRECAUTIONS TO CURB THE SPREAD
OF NINETEEN WILL ONLY BE
EFFECTIVE OF WORKERS HELPED
SHAPE THEM AND HAVE THE POWER
TO ENFORCE THEM. I'VE SEEN HOW
WORKERS AND LAWMAKERS CAN WORK
TOGETHER TO CREATE A BETTER
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL WE NEED TO
WORK TOGETHER AGAIN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR NAVARRO'S AND THANK YOU FOR
SHARING- MAGISTER POWERFUL
TESTIMONY BUT- THE STORY OF
YOUR YOUR COWORKER AND FRIEND
PAS. WHO WE REALLY WISH WELL
AND- AND HER RECOVERY- BUT AS
AS- YOU'VE INDICATED IT. THIS
IS NOT JUST ONE EXAMPLE THERE
ARE MANY EXAMPLES OF WORKERS
THAT ARE. GOING THROUGH A LOT
OF TRAUMA- IN BECAUSE THEY'RE-
BEING INFECTED WITH CHLAMYDIA
OR OTHER HEALTH AILMENTS
BECAUSE THEY ARE BEING.
REQUIRED TO WORK- SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THAT AND FOR A FEW
MINUTES BEHIND IT THAT'S
BECAUSE RELYING FOR TEN TIME
FOR. FULL TESTIMONY AND
TRANSLATION. AND I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
ALLOW FOR THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR.
THE WORKERS TESTIFYING TO
TESTIFY IN THE LANGUAGE OF
THEIR MOST COMFORTABLE IN. A
THESE ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT. THAT
BUT EVERYONE RECOGNIZES WHO IS
DOING THE WORK THAT ALLOWS US
TO BE ABLE TO STAY AT HOME AND
CARE FOR FAMILIES. DURING THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS AND WHO'S
BEING REQUIRED TO GO TO WORK AT
THEIR OWN. A GREAT RISK OF THEM
AND THEIR FAMILIES SO- PLEASE-
SHAPE THE TIME- THE I
APPRECIATE EVERYONE- I
WITNESSES WITH BE OPPORTUNE TO
SPEAK GET THE PROPER TRY. ARE
EVERYONE UNDERSTAND. THE PLIGHT
OF OUR WORKERS WHAT THEY'RE
GOING THROUGH- WE STILL HAVE
MORE WORKERS TO HEAR FROM- I
DON'T BELIEVE ANY. OF THE FINAL
THREE SPEAKERS OF REQUIRED
TRANSITION IF THEY DO WILL
ABSOLUTELY LOVE TIME FOR THAT-
NEXT IS. GOING IS KEEPING IN
THE FOOD SECTOR AROUND. ABOUT
ONE THAT WE HAVEN'T ALWAYS
HEARD FROM IN THAT IN THAT VEIN
AND THAT'S CAFETERIA WORKERS IN
SCHOOLS- AND SO WE'RE GOING TO
BE HEARING FROM DEBORAH ORTIZ
WHO'S A SCHOOL NUTRITION.
DRIVER WHO WILL BE ACCOMPANIED
BY A GIANT SUPERSTAR OF THE
CSEA. AND I BELIEVE SHE'S IN.
THE VIDEO ROOM A ROOM HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. SENATE MAJORITY IS
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MY NAME
IS DEBORAH TEAS AND I WAS GONNA
CHRISTIAN DRIVER AT THE RUSSELL
CITY ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND RESULT. WHICH IS LOCATED
TWENTY FIVE MINUTES EAST OF THE
STATE CAPITOL. I'M ALSO THE
PRESIDENT OF OUR LOCAL CSEA
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION CHAPTER. AND AS YOU
KNOW CSU REPRESENTS TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES AND OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES ACROSS THE
STATE. I'VE BEEN WORKING AT THE
REST WILL CITY ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR TWELVE
YEARS AND I'VE BEEN IN
NUTRITION SERVICES THE ENTIRE
TIME. I'M ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF
OUR LOCAL CHAPTER OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL. NUTRITION
ASSOCIATION I'VE WORKED IN MANY
DIFFERENT FOOD SERVICE
POSITIONS INCLUDING CASHIER
COOK SUPPLY KICKER PROCUREMENT
DELIVERY FROM THE CENTRAL
KITCHEN AND WAREHOUSE. I'M
CURRENTLY WORKING AT THE
CENTRAL WAREHOUSE DELIVERING
FOOD. I GO TO TEN SITES EACH
DAY. I AM VERY PROUD OF MY WORK
HELPING TO ENSURE THAT NO CHILD
GOES HUNGRY SO THEY CAN FOCUS
ON THEIR ACADEMIC STUDIES AND
BE READY TO LEARN. THANK YOU
FOR GIVING US THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE OUR STORIES IN TERMS
OF WORKPLACE SAFETY AND
CHALLENGES DURING THE PANDEMIC.
I WILL BE SHARING MY PERSONAL
STORY OF ROSEVILLE AS WELL AS
SHARING SOME KEY FINDINGS FROM
ACROSS THE STATE FROM OTHER
DISTRICTS. STATEWIDE THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION REPORTS THAT WE SERVE
SIX MILLION MEALS AT OVER
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND LOCATIONS
EVERYDAY. AND ROOSEVELT WE HAVE
TOTAL ENROLLMENT OF ELEVEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS. TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED KIDS IN OUR DISTANCE
LEARNING PROGRAM AND ANOTHER
EIGHTY FOUR HUNDRED AND ARE
MODIFIED TRADITIONAL. WE'RE
SUPPOSED TO HAVE NINETY TWO FOR
SERVICE WORKERS TASKED WITH
PROVIDING TO MAIL TODAY TO ALL
THE KIDS ONE OF THE FIRST
PROBLEMS WE FACE. MEETING THAT
GOAL IS A SHORTAGE OF STAFF.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE FOURTEEN
POSITIONS VACANT AND ARE BEING
POSTED MANY OF THEM WERE
PREVIOUSLY POSTED AND NOBODY
APPLIED SO NOW THEY'RE BEING
REPOSTED. THEY HAVE A STARTING
WAGE OF FOURTEEN TO FIFTEEN
DOLLARS AN HOUR AND MOST OF
THESE POSITIONS ARE LESS THAN
THREE HOURS A DAY SO THEY'RE
VERY HARD TO FILL. UNTIL THESE
POSITIONS ARE FILLED WERE
OPERATING WITH YOUR STAFF THIS
MEANS THAT EACH OF US HAS TO
PICK UP THE WORKLOAD AND FILL
THAT GAP TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
MAILS ARE DELIVERED ON TIME.
OTHER FOOD SERVICE POSITIONS
ARE PROTECTED FROM LAYOFFS AND
THE STATE YOU'RE A BUDGET.
ACROSS THE STATE THERE ARE
NEARLY FIVE THOUSAND LAYOFFS OF
OTHER TYPES OF SUPPORT STAFF IN
OUR SCHOOLS AND COLLEGES. AS WE
STRUGGLE TO REOPEN OUR SCHOOLS
WE NEED MORE STAFF NOT FEWER TO
SAFELY PREPARE AND DELIVER
MEALS FOR STUDENTS. THE NEXT
IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT IS THE NEED FOR
WORKPLACE PROTOCOLS TO PREVENT
THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS. LOTS
OF EMPLOYEES HAVE PUT THEIR
HEALTH AND WELL BEING AT RISK
TO ENSURE CHILDREN. AND
COMMUNITIES RECEIVE MUCH NEEDED
FAILED DURING THIS CRISIS. THE
EMPLOYEES ARE VERY WELL OF THE
POTENTIAL OF CATCHING COVERED
NINETEEN WILL WORKING ONSITE.
AND INTERACTING WITH COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND YET. THEY DO SO
WITH THAT KNOWLEDGE BECAUSE IF
IT WERE NOT FOR THESE MAILS
THESE KIDS COULD GO HUNGRY.
I'VE BEEN TOLD THAT OUR
DISTRICT HAS BEEN SELECTED AS
ONE OF EIGHTEEN IN THE STATE.
TO PARTICIPATE IN A PILOT
PROGRAM FOR SURVEILLANCE
TESTING AND TRACING FOR STAFF.
I HOPE THAT WE GET A GOOD
PROTOCOL FOR THIS TESTING
PROCESS SO THAT WE CAN PREVENT
THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS. AT OUR
WORKPLACE AND THAT ALL OF OUR
WORK SITES. AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT EMPLOYEES ARE GIVEN
GOOD NOTICES AND TRAINING FOR
THAT TESTING PROCESS. THIRD WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT FOOD
SERVICE WORKERS HAVE ENOUGH
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES. TYPICALLY PEOPLE
THINK OF GLOVES AND MASKS WHEN
THEY THINK OF PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. SOMETIMES
THE WORK ENVIRONMENT AND
CONDITIONS REQUIRE SPECIALIZED
PORTABLE EQUIPMENT. FOR EXAMPLE
SINCE THERE'S NO DINING IN THE
CAFETERIA AT THIS TIME. WE HAVE
TO LOAD THE MEALS ON TO CARTS
TO HELP TO GET THEM TO
CLASSROOMS WHERE THE STUDENTS
ARE NOW EATING. THEIR BREAKFAST
AND LUNCH. WE TEND TO FORGET
ABOUT SIMPLE THINGS LIKE HAVING
OF CARDS. SO THAT WE CAN
TRANSPORT THE FOOD. AND THERE
ARE OTHER OF. IN SOME CASES WE
SHOULD HAVE A PORTABLE BARRIER
DEVICE LIKE PORTABLE PLEXIGLASS
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE HANDING
OUT MEALS AT AN OFF CAMPUS
LOCATION. AT LITTLE LAKE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT OUR
MEMBERS ARE HAVING TO SERVE
MEALS ENTIRELY OUTSIDE DEALING
WITH THE WEATHER IS AN ADDED
STRESS IN SERVING MEALS DURING
THE SUMMER WHEN IT'S A HUNDRED
AND FIVE DEGREES OUT TRYING TO
KEEP NO COLD OUTDOORS WITH
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE. AND WHEN
IT'S RAINING THERE ARE NONE OF
CANOPIES TO COVER EVERYTHING
AND WHEN IT'S WINDY THE
CANNABIS CABELO WAY. IN SOME
PLACES EMPLOYEES MUST SANITIZE
THE EQUIPMENT ALONG WITH THEIR
CLOTHES. BEFORE AND AFTER
CONTACT WITH CHILDREN AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. THESE ARE
SOME OF THE KEY ISSUES THAT
WE'RE FACING IN CONCLUSION THE
KEY POINTS I WANT TO LEAVE YOU
WITH OUR ONE WE NEED MORE STAFF
NOT LAST. STATEWIDE CSEA IS
FACING FIVE THOUSAND CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE BEEN
LAID OFF MANY OF THEM ARE
TEACHERS AIDES IN THE
CLASSROOMS WE NEED MORE PEOPLE
NOT LESS TO SAFELY AND
EFFECTIVELY DO OUR WORK AND
PROTECT KIDS AND ENSURE THAT
THEY DON'T GO HUNGRY. TO
TRAINING ON SAFETY PROTOCOLS
EMPLOYERS SHOULD BE ENCOURAGED
TO PLAN AND TRAIN ON SAFETY
PROTOCOLS FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES
THEY SHOULD ALSO HAVE FREQUENT
SURVEILLANCE TESTING ESPECIALLY
WHERE THERE IS AN OUTBREAK TO
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF THE
INFECTION. THREE SUFFICIENT PBS
SUPPLY WE NEED TO ENSURE ALL
WORKERS HAVE ACCESS TO ADEQUATE
PP WE WANT TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
FOR THEIR EFFORT TO PROVIDE
EMPLOYEES WITH PP EARLY IN THE
PANDEMIC. WE MUST CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE APPROPRIATE PP
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
MATH CLASS FACIAL PLASTIC
ESSENTIAL SUPPLIES. FINALLY A
GOOD EMPLOYERS AND SOME
DISTRICTS HAVE PROVIDED
ADDITIONAL PAY OR STIPENDS TO
MEMBERS AND ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF
THE INCREASED WORKLOAD TO
HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS IN WHICH
WE ARE WORKING AND OUR
DEDICATION TO FEED OUR STUDENTS
AND COMMUNITIES DURING TH
PANDEMIC. THAT IS MUCH
APPRECIATED WE HOPE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
CAN CONTINUE PROVIDING THE
NEEDED RESOURCES TO SUPPORT OUR
FOOD SERVICE WORKERS AND ALL
CLASSIFIED STAFF WHO ARE
KEEPING OUR SCHOOLS OPERATING
SAFELY THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE OUR
STORIES AND EXPERIENCE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MINORITIES AND
THANK YOU INTO THE MEMBERS. OF
THE SCHOOL. HELLO TWITTERVERSE
WERE AROUND STATE THAT KEPT OUR
STATE FED. OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS IN AND TO YOUR POINT IT
WITH MY MANY CHALLENGES THAT
THEY'RE FACING TO DO IT- UP
NEXT WE HAVE. THIS SPEAK TO OUR
WAREHOUSE WORKERS SHARE OUR
POLLUTION EXACTED DIRECTOR THE
WAREHOUSE WORKER CENTER I ALSO
WANT TO THANK ME MISTER POSTING
FOR ALSO ATTENDING AND
PARTICIPATING IN OUR INFO
HEARING WE HAD- IN RIVERSIDE AS
WELL. AS A THANK YOU-
MISCONSTRUED. FROM THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN KALRA AND SO WE
MEMBERS MY NAME SHARE COST YOU
KNOW I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE WAREHOUSE WORK RESOURCE
CENTER IN ONTARIO ORGANIZATIONS
DEDICATED TO IMPROVING THE
LIVES OF WAREHOUSE WORKERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THROUGH EDUCATION
ADVOCACY IN ACTION FOR OVER TEN
YEARS WE HAVE ASSISTED WORKERS
IN THE GOODS MOVING SECTOR AND
RIVERSIDE SAMBAR DINO L. A.
COUNTY IS. TO FIGHT FOR SAFE
WORKPLACES SECURE EMPLOYMENT
AND LIVING WAGES TOBIT NINETEEN
IT'S A MASSIVE HAD A MASSIVE
EFFECT ON OUR WORK FORCES IN
OUR REGION COVETOUS EXACERBATED
EXPANDED THE EXISTING
INEQUITIES PRESSURES AND
PROBLEMS THAT WORKERS FACE IN
WAREHOUSES AND IN GENERAL IN
THE FIRST FEW WEEKS OF THE
OUTBREAK WE HEARD FROM WORKERS
WAREHOUSES FOOD PROCESSING
SERVICE INDUSTRIES AND OTHER
SECTORS ACROSS THE INLAND
EMPIRE THESE WORKERS GENERALLY
HAD CONCERNS ABOUT CONFIRMED A
RUMOR AND COVERT INFECTIONS IN
THE WORKPLACES MOST WOMEN NOT
RECEIVED ANY GUIDANCE FROM
THEIR EMPLOYERS OR ANYBODY ELSE
ABOUT THE BEST PRACTICES FOR
STAYING SAFE AT WORK. IN THOSE
EARLY WEEKS MANY WORKERS WE
SPOKE TO A COOK HAD CONTACTED
CAL OSHA HAD NOT RECEIVED ANY
GUIDANCE OR GAUGE BUT FROM THE
AGENCY ON THE ISSUES OF THE
WORKPLACE THE CONTINUED. THIS
CONTINUED AS WE ENGAGED GROUPS
OF WORKERS ACROSS AMAZON
FACILITIES IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. SPECIFICALLY ONE
GROUP IS FILLED RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. ANOTHER IN HAWTHORNE
YEARS LAX AIRPORT. THIS
FACILITY IS VERY SIGNIFICANT
OUTBREAKS OF COLD IN NINETEEN
IN APRIL AND MAY- UP TO FIFTY
OR SIXTY OR EVEN MORE WORKERS
CONFIRMED INFECTED PUFF
POSSIBLY MANY MORE- AT THE TIME
THESE WORKERS COMPLAIN THAT
THEY ARE NOT RECEIVING PROPER
EDUCATION ABOUT THE
TRANSMISSION. OF COVERT AMAZON
REFUSING TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE- SPACE THE AREAS
WHERE THE CASES WERE OCCURRING
AND WHAT WORKERS MIGHT BE
POTENTIALLY AFFECTED. WORKERS
WERE MOVING IN THESE WAREHOUSES
VERY QUICKLY IN ORDER TO KEEP
UP THE MASSIVE NUMBER OF ORDERS
FLOWING AT THAT PERIOD. AND
OFTEN DID NOT HAVE TIME TO
CLEAN THEIR WORKSTATIONS WASH
OUR HANDS MORE FREQUENTLY WHILE
KEEPING UP WITH THE DEMAND.
THIS RUSSIAN AT THE
WORKSTATIONS EQUIPMENT OFFICE
OFTEN DIDN'T GET CLEANED.
SOCIAL DISTANCING BROKE DOWN.
WHICH TOOK DOWN NOTES AND
WORKERS OF BOTH SIDES FILE
COMPLAINTS WITH CAL OSHA- TODAY
WE HOPE TO HAVE A WORKER BE
ABLE TO COME AND SPEAK BUT THE
ON THE WORKERS WE WERE TALKING
TO WERE AFRAID. OF TAKING A DAY
OFF DURING THIS HOLIDAY RUSH.
IT'S NO REPLACEMENT BUT I HAVE
A FEW QUOTES FROM WORKERS AT
THE TIME. ONE WORKER AT THE
TIME SAID IT WAS OPTIONAL TO
CLEAN YOUR WORKSTATION IT
WASN'T REQUIRED. NOBODY ELSE
CLEAN THEM. ANOTHER QUOTE FROM
WORKER A WORKER SAID I THOUGHT
AMAZON DIDN'T TAKE OVER
SERIOUSLY AT THE BEGINNING AND
THE PROBABLY CAUSE A SPIKE IN
THE HEART A LOT OF NEW PEOPLE
COULD HAVE BROUGHT IT IN THEY
SEEM MUCH MORE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE OR NEW ORDERS IN GETTING
THEM OUT THEN EVERYBODY'S
SAFETY INSTEAD OF CUTTING BACK
ON RATE THE EXPECTED MORE
BECAUSE THERE ARE MORE ORDERS.
AND A FINAL QUOTE WE HAVE TO
REDUCE GLOVES AND MASKS THEY
SAID STAY SIX FEET APART BUT
THEY DON'T REALLY TAKE ACTION
TO HOLD PEOPLE TO THE RULES.
IT'S FOR PUBLICITY. CALLOSUM
WAS RESPONSIVE TO THE
COMPLAINTS OF THESE WORKERS.
INSPECTED BOTH SIDES. AND CITED
ARE BOTH SIDES- ON OCTOBER
NINTH. DISSERTATIONS ARE
FOCUSED ON THE LACK OF TRAINING
FOR WORKERS. AT THIS POINT.
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THESE
WAREHOUSES AND OTHER WAREHOUSES
ARE NOT ACTUALLY FIXING THE
PROBLEMS. BUT RATHER SPEEDING
WORKERS UP IN ORDER TO MANAGE
THE COMING HOLIDAY RUSH.
WORKERS WE HAVE TALKED TO. HAVE
SEEN VERY FEW CHANGES IN THE
SAFETY PROCEDURES THERE WERE
HOUSES THAT ARE RECEIVED
CITATIONS. OR IN ANY OTHER
SITES IN OUR REGION. WE'RE
CONCERNED AMAZON OTHER MAJOR
EMPLOYERS. SEE THE SMALL
CITATIONS IN THE STRETCH
CAPACITY A CALLOW SURE. AND
DECIDED THAT THEY HAVE NO
REASON TO COMPLY. OR WORK TO
PROTECT THEIR WORKERS. WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT WORKERS IN MOST
WAREHOUSES AND OTHER
FACILITIES. ARE FACING
DIFFICULTY STAYING PROTECTED.
WORKERS ARE CONCERNED BECAUSE
THEY'RE BEING TOLD THEY HAVE TO
STAY CLOSE WORKING CALL CLOSE
PROXIMITY. BASED ON THE SET UP
THEIR WAREHOUSES. WORKPLACES
WITH CONVEYORS ESPECIALLY MIGHT
HAVE A SHOOT WITH SIX WORKERS
ON EACH SIDE PICKING. SIX BOXES
PER MINUTE OFF THE OFF THE
BELT. SCHERING SCANNERS IN
PLASTIC WRAP. WORKERS REPORT TO
CERTAIN DEPARTMENTS. THERE
THERE ARE CERTAIN DEPARTMENTS
WERE DISTANCE CANNOT DANCE IS
DISTANCING COULD NOT BE
MAINTAINED. AND THESE ARE THE
SITES ABOUT BRICKS WERE ONLY
THE MOST DESPERATE WORKERS STAY
ON. FINALLY WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE ENFORCEMENT OF LEAVE-POLICIES. WE SEE THE AMAZON OF
FIRST REFUSED TO COMPLY WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
WHICH GRANTED FOOD SECTOR
WORKERS TWO WEEKS PAID CODE
COVERED LEAVE. IF THEY HAD A
HOUSEHOLD MEMBER WHO IS
INFECTED OR IF THEY'RE
INFECTED. NOW WORKERS ARE
CONFUSED ABOUT WHAT KIND OF
LEAVE AND HOW MUCH THEY HAVE A
RIGHT TO. WORKERS ARE GIVEN THE
RUN AROUND BY THEIR- BY THEIR
EMPLOYERS BY HR. ABOUT WHEN
THEY WANT TO TAKE LEAVE AND
THAT KIND OF DELAY DELAY ALSO
LEADS TO THE- EXISTING SPREAD
OF CALL OF IT. THIS IS ONCE
AGAIN EMPLOYERS PUSHING
UNHEALTHY PRACTICES FOR THE
BENEFITS OF THEIR SHORT SHORT
TERM PRODUCTIVITY. AND PROFIT.
MAJOR ECONOMIC COMMERCE
COMPANIES LIKE AMAZON HAVE MADE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN THIS
PANDEMIC. THIS COMES DIRECTLY
FROM THE VALUE CREATED BY THESE
WORKERS. AND FOR THE SACRIFICES
MADE BY WAREHOUSE WORKERS. AND
THEIR DRIVER'S. SB SIX THIRTY
FIVE REPRESENTS A REALLY GOOD
STEP INFORMS US IN IN TERMS OF
DISCLOSURE FOR WORKERS- THE
PROPOSED CARLOS EMERGENCY
STANDARD ALSO REPRESENTS A
REALLY GOOD SET OF STANDARDS.
WILL MAKE IT MUCH CLEAR WHERE
EMPLOYERS WHAT EMPLOYERS MUST
PROVIDE AND WE'RE WORKERS STAND.
WE HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
RECOMMENDATIONS. THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING RIGHT NOW IS
ENFORCEMENT. WE'RE WORKING TO
SUPPORT WORKERS ACROSS THE
REGION FACE THESE RISKS EVERY
DAY. I WILL CONTINUE TO EDUCATE
THEM ON THE STANDARDS AND
POLICIES AND WHAT THEIR RIGHTS
ARE. WE BELIEVE THAT THE STATE
NEEDS TO INVEST IN PERSON
INSPECTIONS OF MAJOR SITES.
ESPECIALLY SITES WITH CONFIRMED
OUTBREAKS. WE BELIEVE THE STATE
AND COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS MUST ENGAGE PUBLIC.
OF WORKPLACE OUTBREAKS AND
PARTNER CLOSELY WITH CAL OSHA
TO ENSURE THAT ENFORCEMENT
COORDINATED AND STRATEGIC. WE
BELIEVE THE STRONGER
ENFORCEMENT AGAINST WORKPLACE
RETALIATION SORELY NEEDED TO
ENABLE WORKERS TO STAND UP.
AGAINST A REPORT UNSAFE
CONDITIONS. WE BELIEVE WORKERS
IN A BROADER STATE SET OF
SAFETY NETS. AND SUPPORT TO
FEEL CONFIDENT RISKING SPEAKING
UP. INCLUDING C. EXPANDED PAID
SICK LEAVE MORE FUNCTIONAL
UNEMPLOYMENT APPLICATION
PROCESS AND BROADER JOBLESS
BENEFITS FOR UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS. ALL THESE THINGS WILL
SET THE STATE UP TO FULLY
ADDRESS THE SPEND DEMOCRATS. IN
THE WAREHOUSE INDUSTRY IS AN
ADEQUATE RESPONSE TO IT THANK
YOU. THANK THANK YOU SO MUCH
YOU'RE A MISTER BECAUSE YOU FOR
REPRESENTING THE VOICE OF THE
WORK WAREHOUSE WORKERS AS YOU
MENTIONED- THEY CAN'T GET TIME
OFF TO. TO SPEAK TO US BUT I'M
GLAD TO HEAR THERE. TO
REPRESENT THEIR VOICE
APPRECIATED- AND THEN THE FINAL
OF A WORK REPRESENTATIVE IN THE
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY. IS ZACK
ANDERSON WAS A WORKER- WHO'S
GONNA BE CHIMING IN FROM LOS
ANGELES. AND ZACH YOU HAVE UP
TO FIVE MINUTES AS WELL. YEP
WE'RE GOOD TO GO WHENEVER YOU
ARE. GREAT THANK YOU- MY NAME
IS ZACH ANDERSON AND TODAY ON
THIS PANEL I WILL BE SHOWING
THE REALITY OF THE SIDE OF THE
WORKING CLASS THAT HAS BEEN-
DISREGARDED. AND CASTASIDE AS
A RESULT OF THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC WE'RE FOR CURRENTLY
FACED WITH. AND IF YOU ALLOW ME
pI WILL PAINT A PICTURE OF
WHERE. MANY BLUE CAL COLORED-
CALIFORNIANS FIND HIMSELF AS OF
RIGHT NOW. I WORK AT A RESORT
IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES BY THE
NAME OF TURNING A RESORT. IF
YOU'RE UNFAMILIAR WITH MY
PROPERTY. IS LOCATED IN RANCHO
PALOS VERDES BORDERING PALACE
VERDES ESTATES ROLLING HILLS.
AND ST PETER WORK CURRENTLY
RESIDE. AT THIS PROJECT BOB
PROPERTY I'VE WORKED UNDER MANY
POSITIONS DURING MY YEARS AT
THIS LOCATION. MOST RECENTLY
HOWEVER I WAS A BANQUET
CIRCUMVENT SERVER HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF BEING ABLE TO WORK
EVENTS OF ALL SHAPES AND SIZES
AS PART OF THE FOOD AND
BEVERAGE INDUSTRY. I WORKED AT
THIS PROPERTY FOR ABOUT SHY OF
TEN YEARS UNTIL THE RUG WAS
PULLED OUT FROM UNDERNEATH ME.
THE LAST DAY I WORKED AT MY
PROPERTY WAS FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH
OF THIS PAST YEAR. WHAT WAS
FORCED TO- WHAT WAS FORECASTED
TO BE A BRIEF INTERMISSION FROM
OUR NORMAL BUSINESS SCHEDULE
TURNED INTO AN ANXIETY FUELED
NIGHTMARE. IN THE COLLAPSE OF
OUR CURRENT DAY TO DAY LIVES AS
WE KNOW IT. FOR WORKERS LIKE ME
IN THE HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY.
FOOD HEALTH AND SAFETY IS THE
FOREFRONT OF OUR MINDS AND WE
WANT TO BE SAFE WE WANT TO WEAR
MASKS WE WANNA USE PROPER
SANITATION PRACTICES. WHATEVER
IT TAKES TO GET. HEALTH AND
SAFETY PUT ACROSS THE BOARD. AS
SOMEONE WITH YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN THE INDUSTRY I
WILL NEVER FORGET THAT THIS IS
MY LIFE AND THE LIFE OF OUR
GUESTS WHICH ARE ON THE LINE.
EXPERIENCE WORKERS ARE MORE
LIKELY.TO HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE
TO UNDERSTAND AND SPEAK OUT
ABOUT SAFETY PRACTICES AT WORK.
BUT WITHOUT JOB SECURITY IS
VERY HARD FOR ANYONE TO SPEAK
OUT. THE PANDEMIC HAS LEFT
THOUSANDS OF HOSPITALITY
WORKERS LIKE ME UNEMPLOYED. AND
THOSE WHO DO REMAIN UNEMPLOYED
THEIR POSITION IS MUCH MORE
PRECARIOUS- PERSONAL PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE MINE IS- HI I
CURRENTLY WAS- IN A SITUATION A
COUPLE YEARS AGO. WHERE I HAD
BEEN WORKING A LARGE AMOUNT.
AND IT WAS RANGING IN THE
HUNDREDS. AT THIS EVENT IN
PARTICULAR I WAS- ELECTROCUTED
IN HOURS I FELL TO MY KNEES IN
FRONT OF- MANY PEOPLE INCLUDING
MY- STAFF AND CO WORKERS. I HAD
REMOVED MY- VINYL GLOVES AFTER
I'D BEEN WORKING A CARVING
STATION. AND PLACED MY HAND ON
ONE OF OUR HEAT LAMPS WHICH WE
USED TO KEEP OUR MEET WARM TO
SERVE. WHEN THE- METAL LAMP
CONDUCTED WITH MY MOIST FRESH
AND OUT OF THE VINYL GLOVES. I
CAN ESTIMATE THAT I WAS OUT FOR
A LEAST TEN SECONDS BEFORE I
WAS ABLE TO LET GO AND MY
COWORKER CAME TO MY ASSISTANCE.
MOMENTS AFTER TEAM MET IN THE
BACK SERVICE HALLWAY. WE WERE
REVIWING THE NIGHT SERVICE AND
IF ANYTHING NEEDED TO BE
IMPROVED FOR OUR GUESTS
EXPERIENCE. I RAISE MY HAND IN
FRONT OF ABOUT THIRTY OR MORE
OR LESS WORKERS THAT WE HAVE
THAT EVENING STATING THAT IT
WAS NOT A KID GAS CONCERN. HAVE
BEEN ABOUT- BAD ELECTROCUTION
BY THE HEAT OF THE LAMP STATING
THAT IT WAS NOT- I'M SO SORRY-
AND TO BE CAREFUL BECAUSE I HAD
ELECTROCUTED MYSELF ON THE LAMP-
IN SHORT BASICALLY WHAT ENDED
UP HAPPENING WAS MY SUPERVISOR
TOLD ME WHILE IT WASN'T A GAS
CONCERN- WE WERE FOCUSING ON
WHAT THE- GUESTS WERE GOING
THROUGH AND RATHER DISMISSING
WHAT I HAD BROUGHT TO THE TABLE
IN FRONT OF ALL MY CO WORKERS
IN WAS HUMILIATED. AND THEY'LL
ALL TESTIFY MY BEHALF TO THE
STATE THAT I THAT WAS PUT DOWN.
AND THEY DIDN'T FILE A SECURITY
REPORT. NOTHING SO. BUT
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS PANDEMIC
WE KNOW THAT EMPLOYEES HEALTH
AND SAFETY IS A GUEST CONCERNED
AND VICE VERSA- WE CARE ABOUT
THE PEOPLE THAT WE- TAKE CARE
OF IN FEED- THIS INCIDENT
SPURRED ME SPEAK OUT ABOUT THE
CONDITIONS AT WORK BUT IS NOT
BEEN EASY. IF THERE IS A TIME
TO ENSURE THE PORT THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING
EXPERIENCED AND DEDICATED
EMPLOYEES. NO MATTER WHAT
PROFESSION I WOULD SAY THAT
THAT TIME IS CLEARLY NOW.
INSTEAD EMPLOYEE EMPLOYERS LIKE
MINE HAVE LAID OFF SO MANY
EXPERIENCED STAFF. WITH NO
GUARANTEE THAT WE WILL BE ABLE
TO RETURN TO WORK ON THE
PANDEMIC IS OVER. THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE FOR WHAT TOMORROW
HOLDS THERE IS NO CERTAINTY FOR
THE FUTURE AND RIGHT NOW IT IS
GRAHAM AND THERE'S NO HOPE.
THAT IS WHY HOSPITALITY WORKERS
LIKE MYSELF FOUGHT FOR MEASURE
AB. THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN WHICH
WOULD HAVE ENABLED US TO AT
LEAST KNOW THAT OUR JOBS WILL
BE SECURE AND WE WILL BE ABLE
TO RETURN TO WORK WHEN THE
PANDEMIC IS OVER. I STILL HAVE
HOPE THOUGH. IF EXPERIENCE
WORKERS LIKE ME CAN GO GO CAN
GO BACK TO WORK WE CAN BUILD.
AND HAVE A BETTER AND SAFER
ENVIRONMENT THAN PREVIOUSLY.
PERHAPS THIS HORRIBLE CRISIS IS
WHAT IT WAS REQUIRED TO MAKE
PEOPLE BECOME MORE
CONSCIENTIOUS OF ONE ANOTHER.
IF WE IMPLEMENT THE CHANGES
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS. M-
PROTECT ALL OF OUR HEALTH
IMAGINE THE POSITIVE INFLUENCE
IT WOULD HAVE- I WOULD I WOULD
HOPE THAT WE WOULD BE SO BOLD
TO ADDRESS THAT THE
TRANSMISSION OF OTHER ILLNESSES
IN THE WORKPLACE RANGING FROM
COMMON COLD TO THE FLU. COULD
BE GREATLY REDUCED- WE IMPACT
COULD DRASTICALLY DECREASE THE
TRANSMISSION OF THESE
ILLNESSES. AS A RESULT OF
BETTER HEALTH AND SAFETY
PRACTICES. I ONLY SEE A
BRIGHTER FUTURE ON THE HORIZON.
IF WE INSURE THAT EXPERIENCE
WORKERS CAN GET BACK TO WORK
AND THAT ALL WORKERS HAVE THE
SENSE THAT THEY CAN
SPECIFICALLY SPEAK OUT ABOUT
CONDITIONS IN THE WORKPLACE
WITHOUT FEAR OF LOSING THEIR
JOBS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
REALLY APPRECIATE IT. THANKS
MISTER ANDERSON FOR SHARING
YOUR STORY AND FOR ENDING WITH
OF SOME OPTIMISM THAT THAT I
SHARE WITH YOU AND HOPE THAT
THIS CRISIS. HELPS US SEE I SEE
EACH OTHER'S COMMON HUMANITY
AND THAT THE HEALTH OF ONE.
AFFECTS THE HEALTH OF OTHERS.
SO I'M GOING TO FIRST SEE IF
ANY MEMBERS. HAVE QUESTIONS AND
IF MEMBERS HAVE COMMENTS. SINCE
WE DO WANT TO GET THE PUBLIC
COMMENT WHEN I'M GOING TO ASK
IS THAT A MEMBERS OF QUESTIONS
ASK QUESTIONS NOW. WILL GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT. ANY COMMENTS
THAT OUR MEMBERS HAVE. THEY CAN
INCORPORATE INTO CLOSING
REMARKS- AFTER WE HEAR FROM
PUBLIC COMMONSENSE- WE'RE A FEW
MINUTES ABOUT BEHIND THE
SCHEDULE ON TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THOSE THAT ARE WAITING TO GET
PUBLIC COMMENT HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY SO. FIRST ANY
QUESTIONS FROM.OUR MEMBERS A
SUMMER VACATION THE QUESTIONS.
FOR ANY OF THE OF THE WORKER
PANELISTS. I THINK THE FIRST I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU AND IF
I MAY IN SPANISH FOR MAHDIA.
FUTURE YES PLEASE THAT MIGHT BE
ARE YOU ALLOWED TO GET OUT OF
THIS IS A LIVE FOR SOME FIFTY
ONE YEAR OLD WHEN WE PUT THAT
THE FEWEST AT THE END OF THIS
LIMON YOU- MET BUT THE LATTER.
MY OF MY THIS I. FILLED GUESS
WHO THOSE DID SUPPORT ME. YES
GAP ALTHOUGH MOST OF SAID MUCHO
MAS BUT A BILL THE HIT AND JUST
ABOUT THE LOTUS. THANK YOU TO
ALL OF YOU- ALL OF THE WERE.
WHO PROVIDED TESTIMONY IT MAKES
A BIG DIFFERENCE IN EVERYTHING
THAT WE DO. WE ARE ELECTED TO
REPRESENT TO THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE F CALIFORNIA. AND THAT'S
YOU. SO HAVING YOU TESTIFY HERE
AT THIS INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
THAT WAS PUT ON BY THE-
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT YOUR YOUR
TESTIMONY IS EXTREMELY
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. AB I CAME
ACROSS WITH TO SPECIFIC.
SUGGESTIONS ARE TO SPECIFIC
THOUGHTS AS I WAS LISTENING TO
ALL OF YOU. THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS TO
THAT WAS- TESTIFIED TO BY MITCH
STEIGER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION. IT IS
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR TO ME THAT
WHEN YOU HAVE SOMEBODY THAT
ADVOCATES FOR YOU WHETHER TO
LABOR UNION OR SOMETHING
SIMILAR IT MAKES A BIG
DIFFERENCE YOU HAVE THOSE
PROTECTIONS ARE HAVING SOMEBODY
AN ORGANIZATION THAT IS GOING
TO SPEAK UP FOR YOU. AND FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE LOST YOUR
JOBS- FOLLOWING A LOT IS AND HE
GAVE HIS TESTIMONY ABOUT HIS-
CO WORKER BOSS. IT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT THAT YOU SEEK OUT
LEGAL ADVICE IF YOUR RIGHTS ARE
NOT BEING PROTECTED AND YOU DO
NEED TO. HAVE SOMEBODY ADVOCATE
FOR YOU AND YOU DON'T HAVE A
UNION YOU DO NEED TO ASK OTHERS
FOR THEIR ADVICE OR CALL YOUR
SOMEBODY MEMBERS AND GET
FURTHER ASSISTANCE. BUT THOSE
ARE THE IMPORTANT THINGS THAT I
CAME UP WITH FROM THE HEARING
THAT THIS GREAT TESTIMONY THANK
YOU MISTER THANK YOU SO MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RADIUS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ I BELIEVE YOUR
VIDEO IS READY TO GO. WHENEVER
YOU ARE. GREAT THANK YOU- I
JUST THOSE WORKERS STORIES- I
THINK WE'RE SOME OF THE MOST
HEART WRENCHING THAT WE'VE
HEARD IN QUITE AWHILE. AND IT'S
A REMINDER OF HOW SERIOUS THIS
ISSUE HAS BEEN FOR WORKERS AND
HOW OVERLOOKED IT HAS BECOME- I
KNOW WELL AS THOSE OF US ON
THIS COMMITTEE IN PARTICULAR
HAVE WORKED REALLY HARD TO TRY
TO ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE
BURDENS. OF CODE IN THE
WORKPLACE AND- REALLY DO WHAT
I'VE HEARD- THEM TALK ABOUT IS.
WEAK WE CAN'T SAY SOMEBODY'S AN
ESSENTIAL WORKER AND THEN NOT
TREAT THEM LIKE THEY'RE
ESSENTIAL AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
DONE. NOW AT. IT'S ASTONISHING
TO ME THAT WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO DO ENOUGH AND WE NEED TO DO
MORE- BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND FOR ALLOWING IT TO
BE CENTERED ON THESE WORKERS
STORIES I MEAN- IT. IT'S JUST
SHAMEFUL- THAT IN CALIFORNIA OR
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
THAT THIS IS HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW- AND AS WE ALL COMPLAIN-
ABOUT BEING IN THIS ISLAND COVE
IN ENVIRONMENT FOR THE LAST
EIGHT MONTHS WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER THAT THERE ARE THOSE
WHO ARE TRULY- PAIN THE BIGGEST
PRICES SO I JUST WANT TO THANK
THE WORKERS FOR COMING FORWARD
IN THE UNIONS THAT THAT BROUGHT
THEM FORWARD AND- AND REALLY
SAY AYE AYE IT YOU KNOW I KNOW
AS A COMMITTEE WE WORK VERY
CLOSE TOGETHER WE HAVE CO
AUTHORED EACH OTHER'S BILLS IT
AND TRIED TO. PUSH ON THIS
ISSUE AND I'M SURE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SOME I'M I'M
LOOKING FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
WHAT WE CAN DO NEXT THANK YOU
SO MUCH OF SUMMER GONZALEZ AND-
I AGREE THERE'S A LOT MORE WORK
TO DO AND- I'M REALLY GRATEFUL
THAT A SUMMARY AS AN
ROBERT RIVAS ALTHOUGH NOT ON
THE COMMITTEE ALSO- WILL HAVE
BEEN HERE TODAY AND THEY'VE
ALSO HAD REALLY IMPORTANT BILLS
AND I'M GRATEFUL THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED THAT I KNOW ALL OF US IN
THE COMMITTEE SUPPORTED AND- IT
IS ARE THERE ANY OTHER.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK OR- ASK ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE WORKER-
REPRESENTATIVES ON THE SECOND
PANEL. AND IF NOT I'LL GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT AND WE CAN
ALWAYS COME BACK. TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. IF NECESSARY
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO REALLY GET
TO. PUBLIC COMMENT SO THAT WE
CAN GET THE FEEDBACK FROM THOSE
THAT- HAVE BEEN- WATCHING ALONG
AND CALLING IN. AND SO WHY
DON'T WE GO AHEAD AND DO THAT
AND- I WOULD ASK IF- FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT OF FOCUSING KEEP THEIR-
COMMENTS BRIEF THIRTY SECONDS.
TO A MINUTE MAXIMUM- YOU KNOW
TO EXPRESS YOUR OPINIONS AND
THOUGHTS ON WHAT YOU'VE HEARD
TODAY. AND AGAIN THIS IS NOT
GONNA BE THE LAST TIME THAT YOU
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO INTERACT
WITH THIS. COMMITTEE ABOUT
PARTICULARLY SINCE I'M HOPEFUL
THAT THERE WILL BE LEGISLATION
OR- OTHER FOLLOW UP TO UP TO
SOME OF THESE ISSUES THAT WE'VE
HEARD. SO DIRECTLY FROM OUR
WORKERS AS WELL AS FROM.
ADMINISTRATION REPRESENTATIVES.
OKAY SO WE'RE CHECKING THE
PHONE QUEUE RIGHT NOW OUR STAFF
IS. MAKE A COMMENT OVER THE
FALLEN LINES PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND I
HAVE NO COMMENTS OVER THE PHONE
LINES AT THIS TIME. OKAY THEN.
IF WHAT WE'LL DO THEN IS WILL
GO TO ANY OTHER FINAL COMMENTS
OF ALSO I MEAN I THINK THAT A
SUMMER GONZALEZ AND RADIUS-
MADE SOME COMMENTS. ALREADY BUT
IF YOU LIKE TO MAKE ANY OTHER
IN THE HELP ALL CLOSE UP. OKAY
SO AGAIN THANK YOU TO ALL THE
MEMBERS THAT THAT HAVE
PARTICIPATED EITHER REMOTELY.
OR HERE- IN THE CHAMBERS ON
THIS IMPORTANT- TOPIC AND I AND
I WANT TO. THANK EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING INCLUDING THE
PANELISTS FOR INSIGHTFUL. AND
COMPELLING TESTIMONY AGAIN
THANKS TO MY LABOR COMMITTEE
COLLEAGUES WHO. TIME AND AGAIN
SHOWN A COMMITMENT. TO TRYING
TO WORK ON ISSUES OF WORKER
SAFETY- AS WELL AS TO OUR- THE-
HELLO CONSCIOUS CHIEF- MISTER
PARKER AND THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE REPRESENTATIVE
AND- WORKSAFE REPRESENTATIVES
AS WELL AS THE NUMBER OF
WORKERS THAT WE HEARD FROM
TODAY I ALSO WANT TO THANK- AS
I MENTIONED I'M GONNA GO UP OR
SOMETHING NUMBER COLLEAGUES
pBOTH OF THEIR BILLS OF THE
REFERENCE TODAY PARTICULARLY
THE SIXTY FIVE WHICH WHICH I
THINK EVERYONE AGREED WAS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL. SOMEONE I THINK
IS A MORASS FOR THAT A BILL
THAT I THINK WILL HELP BETTER
INFORM US ON WHAT ELSE WE NEED
TO DO TO PROTECT OUR WORKERS
WHEN I THINK OTHERS AT A DATA
CENTER EMPLOYEES AND OUR
ASSEMBLY SERGEANTS FOR ENSURING
THE HEARING. WAS RUN RUN
SMOOTHLY. I MEMBER DOES ALL
SAID THAT. THIS IS A HERE THAT
REALLY- WAS CENTERED ON WORKERS
AND WORKERS STORIES AND I AND I
KNOW THAT. THERE'S SOME
EMPLOYERS ONLY HAS A VERY VERY
GOOD QUALITY RESPONSIBLE
EMPLOYERS THAT HAVE BEEN DOING
THE RIGHT THINGS I KNOW THAT.
SOME OF THEM OF THE
REPRESENTATIVES WON'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY- TO BE PART OF THE
AGENDA- AND I'M MORE THAN HAPPY
TO CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH
THESE EMPLOYERS LIKE I SAID-
BUT WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
EMPOWERING OCEAN WHAT HAVE YOU
IS NOT A GOTCHA WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO. GET PEOPLE IN
TROUBLE WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
WORK WITH OUR RESPONSIBLE
EMPLOYERS TO DO THE RIGHT
THING. FOR THOSE THAT AREN'T WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE BUT I REALLY WANTED
TO HAVE A HEARING WHERE WE HAD
A WORKERS THAT DIDN'T ALWAYS
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. AND DON'T
ALWAYS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO OUR BODY TO SPEAK TO
OUR COMMITTEE TO SPEAK TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS. THE TELL US TO
RADICALLY AS TO HOW COLD IT IS
IMPACTED THEM. AND THEIR LIVES-
AND SO I WOULD SAY THAT TODAY'S
TESTIMONY DEMONSTRATES. THAT WE
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO TO
ENSURE THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF
OUR FRONT LINE WORKERS. WE'VE
TAKEN SOME IMPORTANT FIRST
STEPS WE HEARD ABOUT SOME OF
THEM TODAY. BUT WE MUST DO MORE
AND WE HAVE TO PLAY A
PRIORITIZE. ADDRESSING THE GAPS
IN OUR RESPONSE TO OUTBREAKS IN
OUR WORKPLACES. YOU MUST
RESPOND MORE QUICKLY WITH THE
NECESSARY ENFORCEMENT TOOLS.
AND THROUGH THE LENS OF
EMPOWERING WORKERS TO SPEAK UP-
AND INTO THE SUMMER- RAISES
POINT YOU KNOW BUT ONE OF THE
BILL'S ABOVE MINE THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED- SPEAKS DIRECTLY TO.
RETALIATION AGAINST WORKERS AND
EMPOWERS WORKERS BUT THE
WORKERS UP AND KNOW THOSE TOOLS
ARE THERE AND THAT THEY THEY
CAN AND WILL BE PROTECTED IF
THEY SPEAK UP. THAT'S PART OF
OUR RESPONSIBILITY NOT TO
ENSURE THAT WE OUGHT AND ENSURE
THE PROTECTIONS ARE THERE BUT
THAT- THE WORKERS ARE INFORMED.
ABOUT THEIR RIGHTS AS WELL.
THERE'S SAID BEFORE- YOU KNOW
WE CALL THESE COURAGEOUS
WORKERS WE DEEM. ASIDE BUT ALL
TO OUR WE TREAT AS IF THEY
SEPARATE. I THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE
ANYWHERE BUT ESPECIALLY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE TAKE PRIDE. IN
RESPECTING OUR WORKERS WHO
SACRIFICED SO MUCH FOR ALL OF
US. AND SO AS WE END TODAY'S
HEARING- I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT- AND AS WE ENTER THIS- THE
NEXT- AS WE ENTER THIS NEXT
SESSION. I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL OF THE MEMBERS NOT
JUST OF THIS COMMITTEE BUT OF
OUR BODY- ARE AWARE OF HOW COLD
IT. IS SO DIRECTLY IMPACTING
OUR WORKERS AND OUR EMPLOYERS
AND WHAT WE CAN DO TO GIVE OUR
EMPLOYERS AND OUR WORKERS
BETTER TOOLS TO KEEP THEM SAFE
SO THAT WE CAN STAY AT HOME
SAFE AS PUBLIC HEALTH. REQUIRES
SO THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH FOR OF
BRITISH SPREADING FROM FOR
WATCHING AND- FOR HEARING. YOU
HAVE ONE COMMENT IN OVER THE
FARM. YEAH YEAH THERE IS
SOMEONE ONLINE- PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND THE
MAN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS KAREN THE BALL AND I'M
WORK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION AT SIERRA
CONSERVATION CENTER IN
JAMESTOWN CALIFORNIA. AS A
CORRECTIONAL CASE RECORDS
ANALYST I AM AN ESSENTIAL
WORKER AND A PROUD MEMBER AND
LEADER AND SEIU LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND. THERE ARE SHORTNESS
THERE ARE SHORTNESS OF SURGICAL
BOOTIES AND CAPS FOR THE DENTAL
ASSISTANT AND DENTAL HYGIENIST
IN THE PRESENT SYSTEM THAT P.
P. R. Y. AS UNIVERSAL. IN
NINETY FIVE ONE SIDE THEIR
BACKORDERED- DOES NOT FIT
EVERYBODY THE ONE FIVE- THAT
CAST THAT ARE BEING MISLED THEY
ARE HAVING THE FIT TEST AT A
STANDING POSITION AND NOT UNDER
NORMAL MOVEMENTS IN THE MEDICAL
FIELD- IT FOR EXPOSED OR TEST
POSITIVE. OR FALSE POSITIVES
FOR KOBE MANY OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT WERE. PUT IN PLACE ARE NOT
GRANTED TO THE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS WE MUST USE OUR OWN.
TIME FOR ISOLATION IF WE ARE
EXPOSED OR TEST POSITIVE ARE
POPPED BUDGET. TEMPERATURES ARE
BEING TAKEN DALY AT THE-
INTERSTATE TWENTY FIRST DRIVE
IN THE WHERE IN OUR VEHICLE AND
WE HAVE MEMBERS OUT THERE GIVE
DOING ART TEMPERATURES BEFORE
WE ARRIVE AT WORK. DON'T
MEMBERS ARE ALSO AB SAFETY
ISSUES WITH THE VEHICLES COMING
AND GOING. AND THE- BAD WEATHER
THAT'S COMING UP. THERE ARE
ALSO SAYING THAT THEY CAN HAVE
THREE TO FOUR PEOPLE. IN THE
SHED OF THE INSURANCE THAT TO
FOUR BY SIX SHED TO STAY WARM
OR OUT OF THE WEATHER. OR
THEY'RE PROVIDING A TENT AT MY
LOCATION. WHICH DOES NOT GIVE
SOCIAL DENSE DISTANCING. WE ARE
BEING TESTED ONCE A WEEK AT THE
MOMENT AND SOME INSTITUTIONS
EVERY TWO WEEKS. ON OCTOBER
TWENTY SEVENTH THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION HAS ISSUED A MAX
MASK MANDATE COVERING YOUR NOSE
MOUTH AND CHIN AT ALL TIMES
UNLESS YOU ARE IN A HAWK HARD
WALL OFFICE SINGLE OCCUPANCY.
HE. AND THAT. HELLO. SO I'M
MEDIA I LET YOU GO A LITTLE BIT
LONGER BECAUSE YOU'RE THE ONLY
ONE THAT CALLED HIM FOR COMMENT
AND ALSO BECAUSE WE DO NOT HERE
TODAY OF COURSE WITH ME WE
CAN'T HEAR FROM EVERY INDUSTRY
AND WE DO KNOW THAT I'M
CERTAINLY AWARE OF THE PLATE
THAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR PRISONS
BUT THE WORKERS CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS AND OF COURSE THOSE
ARE INCARCERATED AND SO THANK
YOU FOR SHARING YOUR
EXPERIENCES AND- THEY'RE
HAPPENING IN OUR CORRECTIONAL
LICENSE. BACK YEAH THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE HAVE WE HAVE THE WE
HAVE TO WRAP THIS UP BUT I
REALLY REALLY DO APPRECIATE
YOU- SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF.
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES WHICH
WE DO NOW- IS ANOTHER AREA THAT
WE'RE SEEING AN EXTREME AMOUNT
OF. PREVENT INFECTIONS- AND SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT. I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN OTHER HEARINGS AND
OTHER CONVERSATIONS RELATED
THAT THAT I ALSO- BELIEVER
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR GOING
TO BE ABLE TO. REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF INFECTIONS AND
SUFFERING HAPPENING AMONGST THE
WORKERS AND THOSE THAT ARE
INCARCERATED AS WELL- SO. THANK
YOU AGAIN SO MUCH AND THE MONEY
TO THE CONVERSATIONS AND I
REALLY HOPE THAT THIS HEARING
HAS HELPED US UP TO SEE HOW
WE'RE GONNA APPROACH THIS NEXT
YEAR AS WERE ENTERING INTO A
VERY VERY. DIFFICULT TIME AS IT
APPLIES TO THE NUMBER OF
INFECTIONS IN OUR COMMUNITY
EVERYONE KEEP YOUR MASS ON-
STATE HOME DURING THANKSGIVING
WITH YOUR IMMEDIATE FAMILY AND-
I HOPE TO I HOPE THAT EVERYONE
STAYS HEALTHY AND SAFE AND THAT
WE CAN DO MORE AS A STATE TO
PROTECT OUR WORKERS THANK YOU.